AN33 Android UI and Layouts
>> Good morning, everyone. So,
my name is nibbling Las and this
is John and we are going to
talk to you today about
constraint layouts.    A new
layout.
>> JOHN: What is layout all
about?  Basically you need to
position this on the screen
based on something that UI given
you, for example, so you have
to lay them out in some
particular fashion on a screen.
What happens if you have
another screen that you have to
layout?  If they are fixed
position, on the new screen, it
is not going to look right.
Things are too far away from the
edges and things like that.
Now how many screens woulds you
actually have to do if you have
to do every screen out there?
5,4 Sunday a rough
5,400.  That is 30 language,
landscape, portrait, many, many
devices.  It will take you a
really long time.  That's why
from the beginning, Android had
layouts.  They are able to
adjust sizes and position things
dynamically for you.  There are
a bunch of different layouts we
can talk about.  You can divide
them into two basic categories.
Simple layouts and complex
layouts.
The classic simple laysought
LinearLayout.  Essentially, you
put your widgets inside of it
and you a rule or column of
buttons or widgets.  Now you can
build very complex layouts just
using LinearLayout by doing
deep nesting but deep nesting
has its performance problems.
On the other happened, if you
use a complex layout, like
relative layout or grid layout,
it will create shallow
hierarchies but without a good
builder to use them, it's
actually very difficult to keep
them stable.  We need something
new to help us with that stuff.
That is why --
>> NICOLAS: That is why we are
now presenting you
conlayouts cornstraint layouts.
And basically it is small in
the
library -- this is designed to
redeuce hierarchies from the
beginning to walk within studio.
And if you started to look a
little bit at constraint layout
already, it might look a little
bit -- between two different
jets -- that seems pretty
similar to what ConstraintLayout
does.  But it does that and
more.  And as it is more
expressive, you should be able
to reduce nesting and as John
said, nesting is not a great
thing for preferences.
It's also in the library which
means not only can you use it
from Day One but we also will be
able to -- push new features
and you will be able to get them
instantly.  It is also -- which
you don't care too much about
that.  But allows us to easily
add new features and finally, it
comes with a great builder that
was created -- the same team
worked on the constraint lay out
and UIBer to make a -- UI
Builder and flex and I believe
easy to use.  We started to
create a new layout system
because we are not currently
happy with the design, but we
just started with something very
genetic.  We need an equation
solver and on top of that, we
had equations but the problem
with that is with the equation
-- we could have stopped there.
We have equation, that's great.
Virtual layouts and that's it.
But the issue with that is it
is very easy for us to create a
system that is not only complex,
may not perform really well and
can also be unpredictable in
the way it reacts.  So that is
why we built on top of the
equation system very simple but
expressive system of constraints
and that allows us to control
the type of constraints and the
type of equation that runs and
on top of preferences.
On top of that, we built the UI
Builder plus tools to create the
constraint for you and further
tools we will demo later.  So,
very quickly constraint model.
If you want to create the
connection, you just drag to a
target.  And the other thing to
do is if you drag that, you can
specify a margin.  That is all
the a connection is.  It's
saying take one side, move it to
a target and possibly keep a
specific gap.
And you can not make those
connections across the bottom,
left, right
and -- at first glance that is
it.  The other thing that is
different and particularly
relative to layouts is what if
you set the connection on both
end.  Both on the left and
right?  If you have a widget
that is fixed size, that sounds
impossible, right?  The left
side cannot be matching it's
constraint at the same time as
the right side matches
constraint if the widget does
not resize.  What we do in that
case is just center it.  And
because it is centered and we
can tweak the result, we let you
decide how much bias you want
to one side or the other.  And
you can also do that directly
into the UI Builder or use the
inspector.  And what if you want
to resize a widget is in this
case, think about it -- we do
not support -- what we do
support is something more match
constraints.  What that will do
is resize the widget so
constraint you define, define
the size of the widget.
And those are important aspect
that is often comes when you try
to do complex UI.  You want the
widget to become.  And the
first case is -- the widget is
invisible.  If you do that,
nothing changes.  That is easy.
Just not drawn on screen.  What
we do is we collapse the widget
that you map as a single point
and we discard the margins.  So
it disappeared but hierarchy of
constraint still applies.  So it
allows to you have a lot more
reactive user interface
behaviors.
All right.  Some of you might
have attributes and yes, we did
build a great UI Builder and we
do think that UI Builder will
create the UIs and make your
life easy.  But if you do want
to use the XML or the
programming you can still do it.
It's a normal group.  You see
you have access to everything.
If you look at those attributes,
it sounds like there is a lot.
But actually, not so much.  If
you look at those, those are the
usual once.  Justifying width
and size and text size and stuff
like that.
To do with us really.  And then
you have virtual attributes that
actually is for the tool.  If
you do things program taically
you don't care about that at
all.  When you push to device,
those attributes get stripped
out.  So really the one we care
about are those in the middle
and really the four in the
middle, manager in and stuff,
you probably know them already.
So we only have two more
attributes.  Constraint on the
left and constraint on the top.
So it is pretty attractive.  We
think the UI build ser great
and if you have issues with your
UI Builder, if it doesn't work
for your work flow, tell us.  We
really want to hear from you
and make your life easy.
All right.  Let's talk about the
layout stuff.  So, we can XM R
and see results directly live
or you can -- XML -- you can
have both views at the same time
or stay with one.  Integrate
into studio.  And we really try
to make it so is there an
immediate feedback.  And so it
is really easy to use.  Things
get predictable and you're not
surprised like you might have
been in the past with whatever
the layout -- wherever you
decide to put the widgets.  And
we just redid this in 2.2
preview.  It's in alpha.  We
welcome reports.
All right --
>> NICOLAS: One of the nice
things the new layout is the
inspector.  This gives you --
JOHN: Iconified view of a signal
womenit that you selected.  The
arrows on the left and right
and up and down show you which
Sites have been constrained, the
numbers show you the margins
that have been set.  And you can
actually just move your mouse
over them and edit the margins
directly.  The slide allows you
to adjust by us if you're
connected on both sides so you
have a bias.  The arrows inside
show whether your wrap content
or spread or fixed width.  Okay.
Let's go to the demo now and
on the laptop.
>> NICOLAS: So you can see that
studio.  And if you played with
it already, that should be
familiar.  And you can see here
it just shows the constraint
layout and I can switch design
mode.  We have two modes, design
mode where it shows what things
look like on the device and you
have the blueprint mode and you
can also have both of them at
the same time if you prefer.
So, why did we do the blueprint
mode?  Because simply sometimes
what you show in terms of layout
doesn't actually appear in the
interface like for example, if
you look at the button.  The
button shows smaller than what
it is.  So the blueprint mode,
think about it as an X-ray of
your current layout and only
show you information that
pertains to the layout.  So, we
constructed so you can drag
wherever you want.  And you do
have some guidelines to help you
position.  We follow the
Material Design guideline for
instance.  And it is very easy
to use.  Without doing any
constraints so far, you can move
it wherever you want.  It's
pretty good when you're simply
playing around or trying to
design your UI how things really
fit.  So if you create the
connection, we just animate
directly.  You can see that if I
don't create the connection, we
still show you what will happen
if you release and create the
connection.  And it works with
the system.  So if I drag a
button and you know, I kill this
connection, everything moves
together.  So, you can see here
it is only constraint.  So
vertically nothing changes and I
can create a connection like
that.  You can destroy all the
connection by clicking this.
And just adding your things and
create those connections.  There
are two different modes to
create connections.  One is this
manual one and I think it is
very important because we want
you to be able to easily tweak
the UI.  But there is one that
is a little bit more easy to use
in some cases, which is the
auto alliance and if we go on
auto alignments.  Auto alignment
works with this icon here.
This little U-shaped magnet.  If
that is on, if I put my widget
on a guideline, it will create
those connections and you can
see small animation as long as
animation is not finished, I can
still move things around.  If I
let it go, then the widget will
be constrained.  So if I resize
-- if I resize that you can see
constraints are applied.  And I
think we talk about tools now.
>> JOHN: One more piece to
alignment that you might have
forgotten.  One of the nice
things about auto alignment is
that when you put an object like
this, the fact that you see the
guidelines allows it to
connect.  So as long as you can
see the guidelines, you'll be
able to let it go and it will
connect for you.  So it could be
a quick way, especially for
very simple UIs to be built.
The next thing I wanted to show
you is, what we call our tools.
So because we are so much rich
UI layout-type environment, we
wanted to add tools a lot like
the stuff that you would see in
PowerPoint or any of the Visio,
or graphical tools.  So, at the
top you will see a collection of
widgets.  And they work in
standard ways where -- where
they align left, right,
middle, that kind of thing.
There is a special mode.  If you
have the magnet turned on when
you issue those, it will
actually create constraints for
you.  So, if you care about
having constraints very
specifically left aligned, you
can use this to -- to tell you
how would that happen?
>> NICOLAS: And it's how we want
the tool to be used in a very
flexible way.  Some people might
just as they go along, just
create the constraints.  Or some
people might just prefer to
layout the widget.  And then
build a constraint.  It's really
up to you.
>> JOHN: So it helps in a lot of
situations like to where you
just aligning things, putting
things together like this,
setting up.  And you can see
fairly quickly I can come up
with a reasonable amount of
alignment and packing of things
and ways we like to use it.
For the next piece -- I wanted
to talk to you about
inference.  Now inference is a
fairly complicated system.  What
we are doing is just one button
.  Don't press it yet.  What we
do, when you press that button,
we calculate the probability of
all possible connections up and
then we walk through a series of
algorithms which will make
connections for you.  By the end
of it, all things will be
properly constrained.  There are
a couple of things that are a
bit magical.  But there are a
couple of things to remember
about it.  Three things to
remember.  It will never really
move a widget on you.  It will
apply constraints wherever you
left your widgets beforehand.
So it's not going to suddenly
push a widget off skew or
something like that.
It will do some small changes
whenever there is -- trying to
do alignment of things.  But
that is okay.  By the end of the
pass, all of the things are
guaranteed to be constrained.
If you have a constraint
beforehand, it will honor those
constraints.  So it will never
destroy an existing constraint
that you have created.  So you
can create constraints and then
let it finish the job for you.
And in fact, in the demos, you
saw, a lot were some manually
created constraints.  Sometimes
it will do auto constraint.  Go
ahead Nicolas and press the
button.  Let's see what happens.
It made a bunch of
constraints.  It aligned
everything.  Now resize the
widget.  Resize the screen.  So
that was done just by drawing
out the widgets in the right
space and it can align them.  If
you didn't like a particular
constraint it made, you can
change it yourself or add a new
constraint.
>> NICOLAS: So for example, I
can still go and destroy the
connections and say actually I
really wanted that one to be
connected on the top.  And
actually here you can see that
we have a couple of modes to
create those connections.  So by
default it creates the Toolbar
on the top.  But if I press
control, it will create with the
current distance and sometimes
that is kind of nice.  Because
if you just want to create the
constraint but you are happy
with the current way the widgets
are positioned, that is a
timesaver.
>> JOHN: So another thing you
can do is if you already laid
out and added a bunch of
constraints but you need a new
piece of UI on the system, add a
new piece of UI in there.  Now,
you can just press the button
again.
>> NICOLAS: The auto connect was
on.  It automatically tried to
create those connections.  But
you can also do it here.
>> JOHN: And it added all the
constraints in to fill in the
widget.
>> NICOLAS: And you can see the
constraint it created was not
the same as the auto connection
one.  And that is actually
because auto connect when you
look at the amounts that are
close to you, so that is why it
shows you the guidelines and
those guidelines if you drop the
widget at this moment, will
create constraints where the
guidelines originate from.  The
auto inference on the other hand
look at the big picture.
>> JOHN: So it might pick things
from based on alignments to
probabilities, fairly
complicated and in the future we
are trying to do like more
advanced algorithms in there.
>> NICOLAS: I want to repeat
what John said earlier.  The
auto inference is not going to
move things around.  It will
very hard try to keep the widget
where you put them.  That means
if you're not happy with the
result, you can still go back
and edit it and it also tries to
make the connection that makes
sense.
That might not be the connection
you had in mind but it say
connection that makes sense when
you look at the entire system.
It doesn't go crazy, that's
what I'm trying to say.  That's
why it is important to have
those manual capabilities to add
constraints.  We see it more as
a -- between you and the tool.
The tool will help you get you
there 90% of the way and save
you a ton of time and just focus
on what is left.
>> JOHN: Even if it doesn't work
out, always undo.
>> NICOLAS: So let's simply
build something common like a
row.  If I want to create a row
like that, I can use the tools
as well.  I can if I just want
to center, I can just do that.
And if I look at the recycle
now, it appears here but of
course it is taking all the
space.  So if I map now the
constraint layouts to be
rebelling om pens, you can
see -- recompense -- you can
see how it is in recycle view.
You can just continue and add
more stuff and that is it.  You
can easily hold your rows.  So
it doesn't automatically have to
work with the UI.  You can use
it for your main UI and you can
use it for something as simple
as a row like that.  It is just
automatic.  And you can see the
result.
And let me just create just to
show you quickly how to create a
new layout file.  So you can
instant preview 2.2.  Loot see
demo.  You just go here and type
ConstraintLayout and what that
will do, it will create the
file.  It actually will
automatically add if that was
not the case -- contains
constraint layouts and you can
then build something.  And you
can still use the design mode if
you prefer the design mode.
That is still working fine.  We
just in that case, show the
different constraint as a
overlay on top of the system.
Or you can just switch to
blueprint.  I prefer blueprint
because it makes things easier
for me.  But the design mode is
really useful to show you how
things look.  So if you want to
just build like a dialogue like
that, you could have something
up just like that and let'ssade
actually use e-mail and
just plain text here and then
you can see that up the
connection was here, up like
that, and that is it.  And we
are doing anything else, I have
my dialogue.  You can see
resides.  If you want to
reinvent -- repent.  Sorry.
>> JOHN: You might want to --
>> NICOLAS: Yes. And you can
still go back and kill all the
constraints and do the
inference.  It does a pretty
good job as well.  And you can
not hear that we constrained on
the baseline for instance.
Another thing that is for the
demo, we can go back to the
Slides.
Just to summarize a little bit
what we showed you.  So, there
is a new constraint.  A new
layout.  ConstraintLayout is a
small undo library.  100
kilobytes.  We think we
developed to move fast and the
new features, it is really built
on top of flexible base.  And
what is good for us is that we
can control and move on the
developments and to make sure
that the preferences will
sustain.  It is compatible with
most things out there and this
is active development.  I want
to -- we just released it this
week.  It's coming just as a
preview.  We want you to check
it out.  Check the UI Builder.
And we will fix the bugs if any
but the reason we announced it
at I/O is because we continuing
is really enough to gather some
feedback and that is something
we are keen on.  We to hear from
you.  Our job is to make your
life
easier.  On the UI Builder as
you saw, the UI Builder is
trying to automatically react to
your actions and to help you,
to give you some guidance and
you can use inference to create
connections to save you time.
You can still go back and just
inference.  And same as the
ConstraintLayout itself.  It's
the same team that works on --
why is why they are well
integrated together.  So, all
that is said for
ConstraintLayout and applies for
the UI Builder.  By the way,
2.2 preview there is a new UI
Builder for ConstraintLayout and
also a new UI builder for the
older layout you already use in
your applications.  If you use
the UI Builder in studio, this
the new one is a step up.  And
this will get better over time.
Let me talk briefly about what
we have in mind for
the next versions.  So if you
remember the slide from earlier
about the equation and
constraints, clearly, we are
going to focus on following the
-- improving performance.  We
have a ton of optimization we
are going to -- obvious ones we
haven't yet done.  So we really
want to focus on that.  For the
equation then we generate from
the constraint, we have some
interesting ideas.
Automatically take them and
simplify them and auto myself
them.  But for
constraint -- auto myself them
-- there is a couple of things
we can do and we could have
demoed it but in addition to the
basic constraints that we
demonstrated, we have the
concept of helpers.  One of the
helpers we have in the preview
actually is the guideline.  You
can create a guideline, a
Photoshop guideline, something
like that, something to work
with and set the guideline and
make it relative to one side or
the other or the dimension of
the container, and simply
constraint your wing tote that
guideline.  The interesting
thing -- widget to this
guideline.  This is not a new
layout.  This is just an object
we used to generate the right
equations.  We have a ton of
ideas of all types of objects
like that to help you create
more advanced layouts.  And also
another thing we look for at
I/O and we know is important is
that all we talked so far with
the demo, let's you create
constraints, position
constraints from one-to-one.  Of
course it can be from one
widget to many widgets for the
two axis but it is going to be
from one widget to do something
else.  And you want to actually
consider positioning and
grouping.  You want to say, yes,
sure.  But I want this group of
stuff to be vertically
positioned.  And we have concept
of virtual containers and
similarly to the guidelines,
those things don't have to end
up in the hierarchy.  So once we
create them, they will actually
appear in the XML as a normal
tag.  You will see them.  But
when we inflate XML, we can drop
on the floor and simply use
them to write equations.  So you
still have the power of using
Groups without the implication
in terms of hierarchy.  You can
think of this system as a way of
decoupling the layout from the
viewer and the shallower the
hierarchy, the better in terms
of differences but also other
things.
One particular thing that I'm
really keen on exploring is if
you have a shallow hierarchy,
that should make your life a ton
easier dealing with animations.
I think if you try to do
animation with very deep nested
hierarchies, it can be very
annoying because something that
is really deep done, you want to
maybe move somewhere else and
it is very difficult to do right
now.  But, if you are do not
have a hierarchy and serving
kind of flat, it's much nicer.
And of course for the inference
and tuning, we have some
interesting ideas in studio and
the concept is simply, we want
you to give you a step up.
Don't start from scratch.  If
you design something, maybe
there is something in what it
gives you that we can use.
And John may have something to
say about that.
>> JOHN: So the inference and
tools are a combination that we
see a lot of future of making
your life very easy.  So one of
the things we want to do is back
the probability ies by machine
learning.  So we look at what
layouts are out there.  What are
all the Google layouts that are
created and see how they are
working and try to learn from
them.  Tools to help you more
easily beautify and organize and
arrange your widgets on the
screen more dynamics associated
with when I put things on the
screen so it will automatically
infer containers and virtual
containers and guidelines and
things like that as well.  So
there is a lot of room to grow
in that area as well.
>> NICOLAS: Thank you for your
attendance.  Check out this code
lab that lets you walk you
through the first steps in using
ConstraintLayout and download
the preview.  There is a ton of
things you saw in the previous
sessions of studio.  You can use
tool studio and we can take
some Q&A now and there are some
mics that you can come up to if
you want.
[ Applause ]
>> JOHN: Thank you.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Heo. Hi. I
was curious.  How expensive is
the on measure and on layout
after this?
>> NICOLAS: That is a good
question.  So I don't know the
preferences are not where we
think they will be because we
just released it so we actually
think that we should be a lot
better.  As I said, there is
optization.  But in terms of
cost, we do one pass for
measuring each widget so, and
unless the widget is set to
match the constraint and in that
case, we do two passes.  So
overall, it should be really
efficient.
>> JOHN: That is pretty similar
to where you are right now.
>> Knack knack match constraint
will be two measures, yes.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thank you.
to do is get users logged into
your app.  It would be easy to
have a ride sharing app where
anonymous drivers are giving
people to nonce muspeople to
anonymous people.  That seems
like a recipe for disaster.  You
want to get people bogged in
and identified so they have
assurance this is a legit thing.
You dock that with fire
Firebase.  You can get logged in
with minimal friction.  So
we'll accept Google Plus log
ins, Facebook, Twitter and
GitHub.  Regular e-mail and
password and if you bring your
own authentication you can
integrate that as well.  The
good thing about this is once we
have user identity, we can
access profile pictures to help
drivers locate passengers
passengers locate drivers.
But if the profile picture isn't
appropriate or missing, what
can you do is use Firebase
Storage to provide a place for
people to take pictures of
themselves and store that in
places.  So, once you have them
stored, then use that to help
drivers and passengers find each
other.  Now, Firebase Storage
is built on top of Google Cloud
Storage and it scales to Peta
bytes of Storage.  It's big.
But that roughly translates to
billions of photos.  So you will
never run out of space when you
need it.  Now, you probably
want drivers to be able to
locate passengers wherever they
are so if a passenger has moved,
that driver needs to respond to
that.  What you can do is use
Firebase Realtime Database to
write the user's longitude, cord
nants into the Realtime
Database and the driver can
receive that in realtime.  So
think of like data going into
the Cloud, into the database and
being distributed in realtime
to those listening to it.  So
not only can drivers find
passengers location, the
passengers can see where a
driver is.  It gives you
assurance that things are going
according to plan.
Now, if you are using
authentication along with
database and Storage, what can
you do is set up rules so that
the data you store in your
database and in your file
Storage is protected by
authentication rules and you
write those rules yourself.  You
determine who can see what
other contents.  So you can be
sure your passenger and driver's
data is see cured safely.  And
-- secured -- you probably don't
79 to be glued to your app all
the time.  So imagine you hailed
a ride and it's like 10 minutes
away.  You don't want to stare
at your app for 10 minutes.  So
what can you do is allow the
user to put the app away and
then send a message to them when
the driver appears and use
Firebase Cloud Messaging for
that.  So you can get users back
into your app at the time
something is important to them.
So for a passenger when the
driver arrives, they'll need to
know that.  Send them hay
notification.  Likewise, if
you're a driver, you might want
to know where passengers are if
there is a passenger nearby who
wants a ride, get a notification
for that as well.
Now, it's worth noting these are
event-driven Notifications.  So
Firebase Cloud Messaging is
great for times when there is
something in the system that
changed and you need to know
about that in the app.  Now it's
a different kind of
notification called Firebase
Notifications.  What this gives
you is a way to type in message
ands send them to the users in
the console.  So you can say,
remind users if they haven't
used the app in a while.  Or you
can say advertise a promotion.
So if you have 20% off rides
send a notification to everyone
and get them back into the app.
Now if you're trying to perform
an experiment you might want to
figure out is it authentication
better shally or late?  You want
to know the right time in the
app to get users authenticated.
So, a lot of people might turn
away if there is early
authentication.  They might not
want to bother with that.  So
far experiment and say, I'll
test out early testing out early
and late after the user poked
around in the app a little bit.
If you want to know which
works better, usury moat config
to perform that experiment.  So
-- Firebase Remote Config.  So
this is a great way to find out
how your app works better for
your users.
Now you probably want to get the
word out about your app.  So
the best way to do that is to
hook into relevant searches.  So
on Google people might be
searching for say, a taxi.  Or
airport transportation.  In this
case, use Google AdWords along
with Firebase, to hook into
those search results and have
your app appear.  It's
essentially a relevant add in
search results to get people
into your app at the time they
are looking for it.
Another way to get users into
your app is with Dynamic Links.
So it's a bridge between your
reb content and mobile content.
It's easy to get web traffic.
It's easy to hook into searches
that way.  Everyone knows,use a
web browedder but you might want
to push people into your mobile
app for that are unique
experience.  So Dynamic Links
can do that.  It's great for
marketing promotions.  You can
say have a special link that
people will follow and then that
links directly into the app for
a first time experience that
keeps them engaged.  And also if
they don't have the app
installed, what Dynamic Links
will do is get you installed
into the app and then it will
take them directly to the
content.  Now, in the past, deep
links always had the problem of
not being able to survive this
installation process.  But with
Dynamic Links, now you can.  You
can get users installed and
directly to the content you
want.
Now there is Firebase Invites
which is built on top of that.
This let's happy users invite
other happy users.
This is word-of-mouth marketing.
The best twiget users.
Glowing reviews from your happy
users are more likely to create
retention for the users they had
refer.  Now invites are built
on top.  All the power of
dynamics links with the
personalization that an
invitation gives.  And we found
this increases retention
drastically.
Now, the last component I'd like
to talk about for this app, the
ride sharing app, is Analytics.
Now it is the core component.
This is the thing that ties
together the rest of the
Firebase platform.  So with
Analytics, the obvious benefit
is that you can know how your
app is doing.  It's worth noting
this is a new component.  This
is not a remake or rehash of
something else, this is built
for Firebase for mobile
applications.  You can know how
people are using your app and
also measure the efficacy of
your AdWords and your
invitations and know how users
are interacting with your app
from external sources and it
works well with Notifications as
well.  So now with Analytics,
define an audience of users who
you want to target.  So say you
want to target everyone who took
a ride in Boston in the last
week or so.  Now get them to get
back in your app and type a
notification and say, we hope
you enjoyed your ride.  Would
you consider taking another one?
So that is 10.  I show 15 up
here.  We only talked about 10.
That is a lot of components.  A
great twibuild a ride sharing
app.  What about the other 5?  I
have a second app idea and it
is totally neat.  It's a recipe
sharing app.  I call it iChef'd.
I'm bad at making mobile app
names.  Run with me with this.
So imagine you have an app that
is Android, iOS and mobile web
and desktop web.  You're
scattering your app and trying
to reach as many people as
possible.  You generally want
your app to be used anonymously
so if people are just doing
regular Web Searches, they might
log in but not logged in yet
but they'll find a recipe,
search for other recipes, enjoy
the app anonymously, but if you
want someone like integrate
their own recipes in your app,
you might want to get them
logged in.  This is how this app
works.  So the first thing
obviously you'll need a place to
store all of your recipe data.
So, you can use Firebase
Realtime Database for that.  Now
it's worth noting that recipes
aren't really realtime.  There
is nothing like dynamic.  Once
you created a recipe and put
data in there, it's not going to
change.  Nothing really
realtime about it.  Realtime
Database can handle that but
what can you do is say, create a
realtime chat associated with
each and every recipe.  So that
everyone who logs in can talk
about it with their friends and
with the person who gave the
recipe.  Your website and mobile
app is much more interactable.
Is that a word?  Interactive.
I think that's a better word.
Now of course you want people
who are submitting resfees take
pictures of the recipe maybe at
various stages so you want
people to upload photos.
Firebase Storage scales massive
lyely and you will never worry
about space again.  Now for the
website of things, if you have a
mobile app, you generally don't
worry about the deployment.  It
is deployed oat user device.
You need a way to get your
static content out there.  You
have HTML and JavaScript and
Firebase Hosting gives you a way
to deploy your static content
over SSL so everything is SSL
protected.  Certificates are
deployed automatically and you
don't have to worry about it.
This is a simple command line to
deploy as often as you want.
It's worth noting that if there
are graphical assets you don't
want to package into your
Android or iOS app, apply those
and then load those as needed so
that can shrink down your
original APK size if you're an
ab Droid developer or the iOS
can be drunk down.  Now this is
important -- shrunk down:  So
having a small initial app is
important.  Deploy the rest of
your content on hosting and load
it on demand.  Get people
logged in and authentication can
do that.  What advantage does
authentication provide?
Essentially encouraging people
to join in and be social.  Say
log in.  Have an identity.  Have
a space within your app.  Let
them interact with each other.
Now do things user-to-user
communications.  Store specific
data per user.  So if users want
to favorite recipes, store that
within their space.  If users
want to follow other recipe
creators, they can do that.
Store information about them and
help them navigate your app
better.
Now I was trying to figure out
how to use Firebase Cloud
messaging?
It's an event-driven messaging
system but how might you use it
in an app like thissan?
Unsung feature in Cloud
Messaging.  When you send a
Cloud message it doesn't have to
contain text of a message you
want someone to read.  You can
use it to ping the app to say
hey, there is new content.  You
should load this and cash it so
when the user opens it up they
have fresh content.  So for
example if you have a user
logged in and they have
favorited some other users, they
want to know when they updated
new recipes, ping the app.  The
users can Kay I have new
download it.  And the recipes
are all there.  This makes for a
very pleasant and more natural
experience than opening up and
waiting for the content that
they were hoping to find.
Now again you can usury moat
config for more things than just
AB testing.  So let's say you
have or doing a massive redesign
of your website.  So everything
is changed, the look and feel
and colors and the whole
experience and you want to log
all at the same time for all
your users at say during like a
television event or some
marketing push.  It's important
it is all available right at the
same time.  In the past, you
might have had to publish a new
app to the App Store and wait
for approval.  Same thing with
the play store T doesn't give
you guarantee when that app hits
the market.  It's hard to make
sure that everyone gets the
experience at the same time.
With Remote Config, what can you
do is essentially create a
switch in the dash board to say,
I want to switch from the old
experience to the new experience
immediately so be sure that
everyone who is using your app
gets the experience you want at
the time that you want it.  And
as a side benefit, if something
goes wrong with that new
experience, say it is called the
app to crash, turn it off.
Revert features having problems
with the flip of a switch.
Now, for apps like iChef'd that
has content on the web and on
mobile apps and they are
parallel.  Generally looking at
the same time on iOS, Android
and the web, use App Indexing.
The advantage there is that
Google will naturally scan all
your web content and index it
and make it easily searchable.
But you can use app indexing to
get content in your mobile apps
index as well.  So all you have
to do is write a few simple
rules to say how your web
content Maps into your mobile
content and App Indexing will
let users do searchings and link
in your mobile app into the
recipe that is they are looking
for.  So if they are on
Android, go to the Android app
and iOS, web to web.  It makes
for a seamless experience.  And
also a benefit of knowing that
usage within your app promotes
rankings within Google.  So if
you have active mobile users,
you can be sure that activity
will help the ranking within
your overall search results.
Now with Dynamic Links, one
thing you can do is link between
remote version and web version.
It's easy to draw traffic to
your website.  What if you want
to push people into the mobile
app?  Say if someone is looking
at a recipe in the mobile view,
and you want someone or want
them to go into your iOS app,
provide a link on the web page,
say view this on mobile.  When
they do that, they can get
installed and get right to the
content anding  you Drive them
to a more pleasant experience
for their device.
My Slides are not advancing.
There we go.  So again, with
invites you want happy users to
refer happy users.  Another
benefit.  So with invite since
they are built on top of Dynamic
Links, what can you do is embed
context in your invites to say
give people a referral bonus to
say, invite a friend and that
friend then gets a 5 dollars off
their grocery bill.
So if you have like a deal with
a grocery store you could say
for everyone who invites one of
their friends we'll give them a
coupon and that makes for a
great first time experience and
greatly increases retention.
There we go.
So again with AdWords just like
before, you probably want to
hook into search results or
things like recipe book and
dinner ideas.  The Google
AdWords integration will
definitely help Drive traffic to
your mobile app and of course
you want to monetize the thing.
You don't want use tours use
this free forever.  You want
them to use it if free but you
need to get paid at the end of
the day.  So add by Google is
another integration.  It's the
same AdMob you already know
monetizing great apps for years
and now it works great with
Firebase.  One new feature in
AdMob you should know about.
It's called native express.
What
it let's you do is include ads
in your app that match the look
and feel of your app.  So this
is great for putting adds in
scrolling list.  So if you added
a scrolling list that looks
like the other items in the
scrolling list, users are more
likely
to notice it and click on it
and should Drive more revenue to
your app.
This iset fromy exciting.
Developers have been asking for
this a long time.  It's great
for games.  Games have their own
styling.  If you can pult ads
in your game, it creates for a
less jarring experience.  And of
course, Analytics again, the
thing that ties it all together,
measure the efficacy of your
invitations and Dynamic Links
and ad words and eventually we
hope that Analytics have even
better and tighter integration.
So, I highly recommend you look
at Analytics.  You can over at
the Firebase tent, we have demos
and you can tauck to people who
are very knowledgeable about
this.
Now I have gone over 13
components.  There are two left.
My counting ask very good.  I
took math in school.  So what is
missing here?  Well, the 13
components I talked about are
great for adding features and
functionality.  Two more things
are left.  What we can do with
Firebase is Test Lab.  We have
Firebase Test Lab for Android.
You can test your app on devices
hosted in the Cloud.  So with
Firebase, we own the devices.
Google owns and manages them and
you can test on them.
This is great because if you
ever done Android development,
you know you can end up with
stacks of mobile devices on your
desk.  And I had this problem
too where I had a cabinet full
of devices and the team I was
working with would grab devices
and get lost.  Never find the
thing you wanted.  You had
tangled cables on your desk if
you were testing on different
devices.  A terrible situation.
You should abandon that and do
testing in the Cloud.  So we
have phones, small tablets,
large tablets across a variety
of OEMs.  They are always ready
and waiting if are you to do
your test.  So if you're an
Android developer, you believey
know you can write -- probably
know you can write
instrumentation test and run
those on your desktop.  It's not
scalable.  You can deploy them
to Firebase Test Lab and we'll
run those instrumentation tests
against the set of devices you
selected and we run them
concurrently.  You don't run
them in order.  You get very
fast comprehensive results
immediately.  If you're not into
writing unit tests and who is?
Writing test isn't fun.  You
can also have an automated test
like crawl your app for you.  We
dhal a robo test.  This robot
here no robot on your app.
This is like an artist
imagination what have a robo
test is like.  But what happens
is, we have software that looks
at the UI wing nits your app and
pushings buttons -- widgets --
selects drop downs and goes
through menu items and if there
is a crash, you will know about
it.  And it takes screen shots
along the way so you know that
everything is rendering properly
on the devices you decideed.
Now this is a device rack.  We
had a photographer come in and
make nice foesose.  This is like
a serber farm.  So I really
want to visit the device lab
some day.  I haven't been there
yet.  We have one on Google
campus and one in Atlanta.  I
think this is fascinating.  We
have a lighter version in the
Firebase tent so if you want to
see what it looks like, we have
a demo for you to see.  Lastly,
there is also a crash reporting
component.  So, you can do all
the testing you want on devices
in the Cloud but users will find
a problem.  So use Firebase
crash reporting to observe and
triage those crashes so grouped
by type.  You can see similar
crashes and order them by
severity so you know which ones
to tackle first.  This should
help your overall app quality.
Now the way I see Test Lab and
crash reporting working
together, is that during
development, you will make use
of Test Lab in the cloudy to
make sure that all of your tests
are working as planned.  Then
for Android, when you publish to
an alpha or beta channel,
another test a prerelease
report.  This is a robo test.
This will give you a quick check
to see is my app launching and
working okay on a variety of
devices?  Then of course your
alpha and beta users experience
crashes and that will report
back to the dashboard and use
that to create new tests to make
sure that you fix those
properly and when you promote
your app from alpha or beta to
production, you then have actual
live production grade crash
reporting.  So this is a great
way to ensure app quality
throughout your development life
cycle.
So that is all 15 components.
Again, you can take as many of
these or as few of these as you
want.  I'm a big fan of using as
many as possible especially for
new apps.  Now I understand
that established apps may
already have solutions for some
of these in place and that's
fine.  Keep using them.  But if
you want to replace anything, or
if you want to create a new app
on top of Firebase that is
great as well.  I have been very
excited to talk to developers
who are going to build things on
top of Firebase.  Now one of
our early access partners Malang
Studio had very specific things
on say about it.  So here is
what they did.  They built three
apps.    It helps couples plan
a anniversary and me.time and a
School of Rock.  Some of these I
believe are not in languages
that are English so beware that
if you download one of these it
may not make sense but you can
see Firebase in action.  Now
what they did is they showed us
this chart of how they used
Firebase and you can see
across-the-board.  They are
making heavy use of Firebase and
they loved it.  So more solid
icons are components they
integrated.  The faded out ones
are the ones they are planning
in the future.  They didn't goat
it yet.  They were excited to
tell us about how they were able
to use Firebase they gave us
some quotes.  The CTO of Malang
Studio said:
[ Reading ]
Now I love in LEGO brick
analogy.  This is how we
intended Firebase to work.  We
give you these components and
created infrastructure you don't
have to create.  You can focus
on user's experience.  And their
CEO went on to say:
[ Reading ]
We are saying here that as an
app developer, mew you might
have to assemble something from
a bunch of other components but
with Firebase you get one thing
that gives you all the core oral
of your infrastructure you
need.  Once you have that in
place, you don't have to worry
about server farms or scaling up
or creating revenue or drawing
users into the app.  All of that
is there.  You can focus on the
app and your users and the
experience they want to have.
So that is all I have.  If you
want to learn more about
Firebase components, there is
another talk here at 3 p.m.,
Todd will talk about how the
individual clusters of
components work well together.
I like this talk.  I like the
idea that components are like
LEGO bricks.  He will provide
that experience.  If you have
any questions about Firebase,
visit any one of these URLs.  If
you want to get deeper into it,
there is a code lab called
FriendlyChat.  You will actually
walk through the integration
like 7 or 8 components and see
how they work and then
FriendlyPix, a live app which
will demonstrate a lot of
Firebase features.  I'm really
excited about Firebase and I
can't wait to see what you
build.  Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Now we have a few minutes left.
I'll take some questions.  I
think there is microphones in
each aisle.  So if you have
anything, please let me know.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hi. Do you
plan at some point to integrate
phone number base log in?
Because you know, we talk about
mobile and e-mail and password.
It's adapted and it's kind of
useful to have like a SMS-base.
So are you planning to
integrate into the future?  I
mean understand with custom log
in but if it is by Google that
would be better.
>> Dug Doug so looking for SMS
or like phone number based
authentication?
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Yes.
>> DOUG: I don't know of any
plans for that but I know that
is something hay lot of people
want.  I think if you join us at
the Firebase tented, there are
people who are more
knowledgeable about
authentications.  It doesn't
exist
today.  Stay tuned and find out
what the we have in the future.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thank you.
>> DOUG: Anyone else?
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hello. Is
there
if it looks right, it is right.
So ma what they are seeing is
the UI in terms of what the user
believes.  The trick we use is
that we only create and layout
the views the user can see right
now.  And as the user scrolls,
we continue to layute more
items.  The image you should
have in your heads right now is
the bit from Wallace and grommet
where you're quickly laying the
track in front of the moving
train.  And it uses adapter
components.  This is a component
provided by the application
itself.  And it is used to
create and populate the item of
views on demand.  You got get
view method in the adapter used
to query the adapter for a
particular view to show a data
item that corresponds to a
particular position in the list.
And the extra trick we do is
pass in a special convert view
that is guaranteed to be of the
same item type that the adapter
believes that new position to be
so you can reuse the same view
and you don't have to pay the
cost of inflation again.
And over time, we continue to
add more and more features to
ListView because there were
things that people needed in
their apps.  And this question
kind of came up a lot.  So,
ListView grew feature after
feature and you can go back and
watch this talk from I/O 2010
if you want to see a few of
them.
>> Really nice. You should
watch it.  I enjoyed it.
>> If you want to see our
classic Us and some of that talk
as well.  Yes.  As we kept
adding features, we hit a
complexity overdraft point the.
We had so many features that
kind sorted interacted with each
other but all a little bit one
off and all of these long
features
that led to a lot of very
strange interactions and what
that meant in practice is that
everybody wrote their apps such
that things worked how they want
today to but a lot of things
they were the result of
undefined behavior in ListView
implementation itself.  And once
enough apps start doing that
that is defacto API we have to
support.  Any small change we
have to do to improve for core
cases ends up breaking some apps
that they want to use some
place else.
We also have a lot of duplicated
functionality in ListView.
Like ListView selections or view
focus.  Which ones do we use?
The view hierarchy already knows
how to hand keyboard focus but
ListView had its own idea of
this in terms of current
selection, selector drawable
drawn behind or over the views
depending on the config Ages you
set up and -- configurations.
And this led to overlap and
meant that if you start using
more complex views in your
ListView items, you have to
switch over to the set items can
focus option that disables
ListView internal selection
handling and lets you use the
focus handling instead.
Similarly, we had the same issue
around item click listeners
versus view click listeners and
general touch handling.  So
ListView provided a very nice
convenience where you could set
an item click listener on the
ListView itself and get clicks
for anything that happens in
this list.  This makes sense for
list that are uniform where you
have a list of items and you
just want to pick something from
it.  Like a pop up menus we
have from the overflow menu of
your apps today.  But,
ultimately, you can also just go
ahead and attach click
listeners to these views
themselves and which one was
going to handle the events was
sometimes not always clear or
intuitive.  So people ask us a
lot of times, which one do I
use?  The answer always ended up
being, it depends.  How complex
are your list items?  And any
time you have to very a lot of
types of clarifying questions
about like, okay, what are you
trying to do?  Then that really
kind of complicates the
developer story.
But really the big thing that
kind of kicked off the whole
RecyclerView effort was that
ListView animations are really,
really difficult.  And the core
problem is that adapters don't
tell us enough to do them smart.
So,
when you change an adapter, you
say notify dataset change and
the assumption is, anything
could have changed.  We are not
entirely sure what and we are
just going to go ahead and
rebind the items visible and go
from there.  And over time, we
had a few prototypes, some of
them done by members of the
team.  Some of them done by
members of the community.  All
to try to show items animating
in and out as the dataset
changes and do
so in a way that is intuitive
but all individual really major
limitations.  Most of these had
to do with again, internal
implementation and details of
ListView that absent come to
rely O we couldn't fix these
things to make them possible.
So, actually just end up making
this face in ListView.
>> YIGIT: Look at the regret in
his face like I'm not sure I
should do this.  Like I'm I'm
going to regret this.
>> Ad he wear this is face a
lot.  And this is a duplicated
functionality.
>> YIGIT: Like the Slides.
>> ADAM: So as we moved on,
people started to use much, much
more complex layout in their
ListView items.  We went from
something like that very simple
setting screen in gingerbread to
suddenly people showing items
from a full social stream with
many different components and
points of interaction.  So, the
simple grids and list we
provided with lis view and grid
view weren't enough to handle
these use cases appropriately.
People started wanting to create
these sorts of staggered grids,
responsive layouts and so
forth.  And really if you wanted
to change these types of
layouts, you were rewriting a
lot of core code thatless view
used to do this adapter base
recycling.  So if we have a do
over, what would we change?  One
of the things we wanted to do
was to elevate the best
practices of working with
ListView to first class API.  We
had a view holder pattern that
we went over in the world of
ListView talk linked earlier in
the talk here, and the nice
thing about the view holder
pattern that existed for
ListView, it gave one point
where you could collect a bunch
of attributes about a
RecycledView you were going to
work with and have that single
point of access.  Cache a lot of
these by ID calls you make to
inflated view sub hierarchy and
on older devices that made a big
difference and as you wereet
craking more and more complex
item layouts it mattered even
more.  We thought let's go ahead
and make that part of the core
API.  Instead of having this be
a best practice that everybody
has to read blog posts to figure
out, let's make sure this is
something that you see as soon
as you read the documentation
when working with RecyclerView.
We wanted to separate view
creation and binding.  This was
something that happened in the
cursure adapters that many have
probably used if you work with
sequel databases or content
providers as your backing data
source for your ListView
adapters.
We separated out on create
versus on bind step in those.
But if you're just writing a raw
ListView adapter yourself then
this was essentially a question
of the very first couple of
lines of code in your get view
method where if convert view
equals null then fall through
and do the binding there.  And
this was one of the things that
was fairly easy to forget to do.
If you forget do it, then that
means you lose out on this
recycling mechanic that ListView
gave you to boost your
performance.  Sometimes it
wasn't really clear why this was
happening from the outside.
And next we really kind of
wanted to throw out a bunch of
this selection handling that
really only made sense for these
very simplified list and just
rely on the framework's normal
focus and input
handling.  Because this was
again just comes down to
simplicity of working with the
rest of the framework and
reinforcing the consistency of
working with the rest of the
view hierarchy.
And then selfishly, we also
wanted a little bit more easier
maintenance on our end because I
don't know if any of you have
taken a look at the interns in
AOSP, I'm pretty sure it could
be used to
scare small children.  So we
wanted to keep the core
universal.  So all of those
things that were a total pain to
rewrite yourself if you tried
to write your own recycling
container, we wanted to have a
way to give that to developers
more or less Federal free in a
canned form so they didn't have
to sort of rediscover all the
things we had to do the hard
way.
And we wanted to make sure that
you could still implement all of
these other long tail features
that ListView provided as API on
ListView itself as other plug
ins that we could sort of share
and mix-and-match to get the
experience that you wanted.
We needed smarter adapters too.
Again, the problem with
ListView adapters is you could
say notify dataset changed.
Okay.
What changed?  I don't know.
And that was about all you knew.
And this makes animations
really difficult.  We'll get to
that a little bit further on
down the line.  So RecyclerView
adapters tell us what changed
not just that something changed.
Now if you're working with a
data source that doesn't provide
that sort of fine messaging,
still use the old ListView
style, something changed, go
forward it out.  We'll make a
best effort attempt at dealing
with it but really if you have
any knowledge of what the
specific changes in your dataset
are,
you can get a lot better
results.
So this also means that we can
do more efficient recycling not
just animations.  If we know
that only a particular item in
the adapter changed, then we
don't have to rebind everything
that is on this screen.  We only
have to rebind that one view
and this can safely a lot of
time in the measurement and
layout phases of applying
updates.
>> YIGIT: So, that was
recycling.  So make mistakes we
learn from ListView now like
okay, how do you write recycle
view not repeat the same
mistakes?  And the major thing
you recycle view is we tried to
make the architecture of recycle
view and we will go through the
details of it.  I think it is
very important.  I believe most
of you already use it.  It's
good to know who does what and
which one you should use or
customize depending on use case.
So we have recycle view the
main view.  Major components.
LayoutManager and item and then
adapter.  So LayoutManagers most
provide content yourself and a
good default one to write
yourself so late manager
positions the wheels,
ItemAnimator animates them and
then adapter provides the wheels
and recycle is the bootses.  So
center allocation that
communicates with all these
components make them work
together.  So we look at the
layout manager.  It has linear
list.  It has recycle view.  It
doesn't know or doesn't care
about how items are laid out.
Or scrolling.  Recycle view
handles like the interactions
with the finger but tells the
LayoutManager to scroll because
the LayoutManager knows where
the views are.  Sore if your to
focus reversal because the V
framer handles it.  But if
you're focusing and need one
more item, it is the layout
measure that brings it because
it didn't exist before.
Accessibility.  Recycle provides
basic information about those
items but LayoutManager is the
one that knows the title or you
could custom delegate to say
like focus on this or initial
information that only you can
provide.  Rye cycler view
delegate API for this.
>> ADAM: So similar to ListView,
RecyclerView still relies on
adapters.  RecyclerView
adapter's responsibilities are
to create the view but also to
create the view holder.  And the
view holder is what we really
use as the tracking element for
recycling.  So, when you're
binding an item, you don't just
bind to the view, you bind it to
the whole view holder.  This is
something to use to tissue
other information as well.  Of
course it's the adapter's
responsibility to notify changes
that happen to the dataset or
if the data is out of sync.
So, in contrast to ListView
where you can use this item
click listener type of model for
things, the adapter is
responsible for configging the
item interaction handling.
These are your click listeners,
and touch listeners and so on.
Adapters also deal with your
multiple view types and sort of
being able to keep track of the
different ViewHolders that you
may be tracking.
>> YIGIT: In the ListView world
you need to give us how many
wheel types you have verses in
RecyclerView they are unlimited.
So I suggest just use our
layout as the main type.
>> ADAM: Right. So your view
type IDs no longer need to be
contiguous.  So as long as you
have any sort of unique
identifier that you
can use to identify a view
type, then go ahead and use it
and RecyclerView isn't going to
care.  That means you can use
this handy trick of using layout
resource ID itself and since
APT already gainer these ID will
be unique, it makes a pretty
good stand in for that
identifier.
Went too fast there.  So the
adapter also deals with things
like recycler recovery.  We have
an on fail to recycle view
concept.  So why get something
fail to repsyche toll view?  We
are trying to keep in mind that
people are doing more and more
complex things with their UIs
and in those cases you might
start making a lot of changes to
your views that are very
difficult to reverse.  So, in
those cases, where we know a
view has been left in an
inconsistent state, then we can
communicate that back and forth
to the adapter so the adapter is
able to recover from a case
where a view has been messed
with kind of beyond the normal
bounds of expectation.
And again, we have the granular
data change events as added to
sort of handle efficiency and
performance.  Animations.  That
one.
>> YIGIT: So let's deep dive
into the holder.  Because
everyone needs this and you
spend most of your time there.
It is important to know the life
cycle of a view holder.  So we
will go through it.  What
happens when you create it.
What are the stages?  So while
the layout measure is
calculating layout, it tells
RecyclerView, get in position 5.
So it wants to get in that
position, recycle view checks
the cache because if you already
have it in the cache, we will
return it to the lie out
manager.  If not --
LayoutManager.  So if you didn't
have it, recycle view will ask
adapter what is the type of this
field?  And adapter returns,
double check the pool.  This
might be a shared pool like the
RecyclerView.  Do we have a view
holder for this type?  If it
says no, we tell adapter to
create one.  So this is when we
create a view holder.  Or maybe
the pool returned the item and
it will tell adapter bind this
position to this view holder and
runs and give it back to the
layout manager.  Layout manager
will edit lack to recycler and
tell that adapter this has been
added to layout.  This is say
good hipt for your adapter to
know that okay, users about to
see this field.
So other case where layout
measure say okay remove and
recycle this view.  Okay I
remove this view let you know so
if you have things inside that
view, you can on cache remove
from memory.  And then we will
check, okay is this view level
lit for this position?  If it
is, we will cache it.  The idea
is that if the lab measure
aspect for that position again,
we can give it without talking
to the
adapter.  This is again for
performance reasons.  And the
cache -- I will tell that
operator, we got rid of this
view now you know it will be
used for that position so you
can even further memory cleanup.
>> ADAM: This is a important
step learned from ListView.
Where ListView added this
RecycledView listener used to
track when a view was no longer
in use and again because people
create much, much more complex
UIs in these sorts of recycling
contains ethis allows you to
take a step and say instead of
leaves these built Maps attached
to views being held in a cache
off screen, let's clean those
things up but still retain the
core view structure so we can
rebind it later.
>> YIGIT: So if it is not well
lit, so say maybe the item has
-- because adapter told us or
item was changed and the
contents of the view doesn't
represent that position anymore.
We send it to the pool and
tell adapter about it.  Another
use case where LayoutManager
recall layout after some adapter
changes and that doesn't use
some of the views.  So, all the
views from one-5 let's say and
that makes -- only use 8 and
other two are missing.
RecyclerView says we understand
the LayoutManager doesn't want
these views anymore so but you
may want to fade them out
instead of disappearing them
instantly.  So for each
disappearing, it will make them
children again and hide them
from the LayoutManager.  We will
go into details later but the
list of children from the layout
mother-in-law's perspective are
not -- from the LayoutManager's
perspective are not the same.
So it will tell them to make
children and it says okay, I can
do whatever you want then
RecyclerView will remove them
and tell the adapter they are
going away.  And then we will
recycle it.
So, how do we lose a view
holder?  This is very important
because if you're losings view
holder you will hit problems.
So same thing happened.  I want
to get rid
of this view.  RecyclerView is
like no, okay I approximate ut
this into the pool.  And the
pool -- this is what Adam
mentioned earlier.  If we have
animate        animating
contents, you have a button
doing animation.  That means if
a view is animating, we cannot
use it for other view holder.
Imagine it phased out and the
bind it to something else and
then it is faded out.  You want
fresh views.
>> ADAM: A few other cases to
cause views to have a transient
state as well.
This is part of the framework
not just RecyclerView itself.
So for example if you have a
edit text widget a piece of text
the user entered and they
created a selection across
several words but maybe not
others.  That is this complex
interaction the user created we
didn't want to make the
developer's responsibility I to
sort of track and restore that
if that particular item is
rebound across other context.
>> YIGIT: So what will happen is
that now we cannot reue us that
view and reare removing so we
give it a chance.  Hey, I could
not recycle this view.  Can I
recycle?  Because most of the
time it is because of
animations with selection, you
can recover from that state.
The only problem is that we
cannot do it because we don't
know what is going on.  So you
can add animations or clear
selected state.  Or you can even
say do not -- I know I fixed
this -- like recycle it.  I will
use it.  Or if the adapter does
not provide this method, by
default, it returns false.  So
we will have to destroy the view
holder.  So you don't want
this.  The moral of the story is
if -- don't create animations.
We had the animator to do these
things properly.  So if you
want to animate, and they
receive correct life cycle
events so that we can recycle
and take care of recycling views
animating.
>> ADAM: You can forget about
everything that just happened on
that slide before you as long
as you implement the
ItemAnimator interface.  If
you're doing it yourself, you're
on youren and will you have to
handle all these problems
yourself.
>> YIGIT: The major thing you
start using recycler, you need
to forget everything you learned
in ListView.  Also some bits
are not valid will hurt you
hear.  So another use case where
we will lose views is recycle
viewer is I downloaded this
view, we tried to put it into
the pool but spool limited per
size per item type.  So, if you
have way too many types, like
you know what?  We have no space
for it.  Throw it out.  So why
would this happen?  Why would we
create views that we already
have developed them unused in
the pool?  Well, this usually
happens if -- so if you have too
many older types, why will it
happen is mostly because of
animations.  Like you told us, I
have seen this.  We are like to
make it animate ed, so if you
say something like this,
recycler is like, looking for
every visible child by default
behavior.  I have to create
another view holder to represent
the child so I can cross them
-- crossfade.  That means you
duplicate the number of
ViewHolders.  Those animations
are finished and you try to put
them all back to the pool and
they are like, I don't need this
many items.  Just throw them
out.  So don't do that.  When an
item changed, tell us what
changed is really, really
important.  And correct
animation.  Or other cases you
notice the views are being lost,
you can change the type, the
size per type in the pool.
>> ADAM: This comes up when you
have cases where again social
streams are really big use case
for this as well.  You might
have some posts that are very
long that fill an entire screen
by themselves or might have
several posts that are similar
very short.  And if you have
items that are drastically
different sizes like that, then
the number of items that can be
attached at one time is going to
vary pretty greatly.  Those are
cases where you want to measure
what your app behavior is under
use cases and tune the size of
the RecyclerView pool
accordingly.  So item
animators.  Items common to go
over time.  And again we want to
use a smarter way of figuring
out exactly what it was that
changed.  So let's say we added
a new item in between H&I in the
diagram here.  So now we have P
in the middle.  So no longer
sorted.  Ignore that.  What
happens if something disappears?
Well, now we have another
image of a list.  Now the
interesting thing here -- and
then of course we have the case
where an item simply changes and
it's contents change in place.
So the interesting thing in
these cases is that there is
always some side effects when
you add and remove views.  So,
we added view P here. I&J got
moved down and K is completely
gone.  When we remove something
really similar happens.  So, we
remove item H, I, J, K, but L is
new on the screen.  We had to
get a new view in order to show
it in that case.  So, without
extra information -- sorry.
Change, first.  And of course
this is one of the easy cases.
We can just go ahead and
crossfade between these.
So, if we are handling things
this way, if an item is removed,
we can fade it out.  When an
item is added we fade it in.
And if an item is sort of moving
around on screen, we can
Translate T our default item
animation handlers can handle
this no problem.  Changing, we
just on do a simple crossfade in
place.  As long as we don't
have cases where that item
changed size, we are in a super
easy case.  Otherwise it means
other items are moverring and we
get into the same cases as
before.  But can we do better
than this?  There is kind of a
key problem in these cases.
Which is that if all we know is
that something changed in the
adapter and here is the new
state, like with ListView, then
how do we really tell the
difference between an item that
was removed from the adapter
after this versus an item that
just was knocked off screen and
is no longer there?  When we are
putting together these sorts of
animations, this is suddenly
really important.  Similarly,
how do we know if something came
on screen because other things
moved around it or if it is a
new item in the adapter itself?
Again, without their being a
representation of those views
attached to the parent from the
outset, we don't necessarily
know.  So we can do better
because now we know this.  We
know that conceptually, coming
back to this smoke and mirrors
analogy from before, even though
we only have a certain number
of items attached to the group
at a time, conceptually we have
a lot of items that come before
and after what is being shown on
screen.
So, we can get a little bit
predictive about this if we are
willing to ask the adapter some
additional questions and
specifically in conjunction with
the layout manager.  So, as we
add this item here and we have
to delete K, in this case we
know that K is still present if
the adapter hasn't told us it is
gone.  We know it is just
sliding off screen instead.
Similarly with removal we can
use the same trick.  We can ask
the layout manager show stuff
around what I'm doing so I have
the added context to be able
toic ta the before and after
states and animate it
correctly.
>> YIGIT: So, the way this
works about ItemAnimator is the
prediction animations is the
RecyclerView can show a view of
the adapter in the past.  So how
we can do this is like if you
have new items in the adapter,
we don't tell them the layout
manager because it always sits
in between.  What we do is we
show a different field.  For
example, before we plotted that,
there was layout manager in
animator and the a view and is
that a always fight this view is
might happen no this is mine.
Wait I want it animated, wait I
want to recycle it.  So always a
conflict.  The way we solved
this is ChildHelper.  When
LayoutManager says I want to get
the child in the position or
remove it or do whatever I want
it, RecyclerView doesn't call it
um.  We don't change the
children instantly.  We start
with the com Pope ent that is
responsible to create this
contacts.  And then the
ChildHelper decides layout
mother-in-law told me to remove
it but ItemAnimator told me to
animate it so I will keep it
until animator is done.  We
don't want layout managers to
get more complex trying to
understand animations so for the
layout memory they look like
they disappeared but they are
actually real children in the
real world.  So, child is
responsible to provide virtual
list to the layout
mother-in-law.  So for example
-- LayoutManager.  Let's assume
this view has been removed.  So
while you remove animations if
the LayoutManager tries to get
the child in third position, it
is going to return Barcelona and
if the RecyclerView if you try
to get RecyclerView child it is
-- so between these components
helps us with these things
without making this complex.
And animation is complete, they
start to return the same.
AdapterHelper is the same thing
but doing the same -- so when
you like have that adapter send
all notified changes a bunch of
things happening in the list and
it is like what is going on?  I
have no idea what is going on.
It is hard for LayoutManager to
track things because it is
already busy checking UI.  So
AdapterHelper is to the rescue.
So when you say notify item in
adapter, we record it and
request a layout.  We know
something happened.  That's it.
The only thing we do is keep
the information about it.  And
now as you add more notifiers we
keep them in a list.  Let's say
during this moment before we
recalculated the layout we know
adapter contents have changed,
user clicked on the button.  And
you want to get the item.  Get
in position for item at 59 which
was clicked.  But we know there
is a new item in this so we
know that in that adapter it is
at position 6.  So even if it is
not recalculated if you need to
access your adapter items, we
provide you the right position.
So, this simply happens by
checking what you told us
before.
And let's say you send more
updates.  And then we will go
through them, it request layouts
honored by the system and start
preparing new layouts and
then this time, the adapter is
going to provide the
LayoutManager the fake
positions.  So how does it work?
What we do is when I talk
about faking the adapter
contents, is we reorder your
updates first.  So the idea is
everything we have to tell to
the lab manager first we tell
about them.  And then everything
else we tell about them later.
So if you look -- you remove two
items from 61, we know that 61
we reordered -- okay.  If you
want this removed, run
LayoutManager
recalculating previous state, -
asks for item 60, I can provide
it.  I don't know to tell
LayoutManager that item has been
deleted but item 61 I don't
have it.  So what I do is divide
that new operation into two.  I
tell the LayoutManager, like
before you callculate the
layout, the item 61 is gone.
Just let you know.  It does the
preplay out, guess to the post
layout phase and this finding
adapter updates tells or enables
us to fake that content source
LayoutManager so all it has to
do is ask it to layout twice and
then predict all the rest of
the animations so almost need to
know anything about that.
>> ADAM: All right. We'll try
to move some of other features
here a little bit more quickly.
So ItemDecorations.  ListView
has the ability like many other
one off features in ListView to
draw dividers between items.
And so we needed to make sure
this functionality was
preserved.  So ItemDecorations
allow you to do custom drawing
on the RecyclerView canvass
itself.  Not necessarily just
individual items within it.  We
can also go ahead and add
offsets to view bounds using a
test case of the divider you
need to make sure have you
couple pixels of space the
divider consumes rather than
drawing over or under the item
views.  And you can also have
multiple ItemDecorations.  They
stack.  These ItemDecorations
can affect views again in sort
of a stack-like manner.
ItemDecorations so we can draw
items over our list
items here -- come on.
So, another important thing here
is the get item offsets.
This is really what lets us add
space.  This is nice if you're
doing a card background around
several items at once like a
grouping of some sort.  But you
can also do it on single items
too.  So we can expand the space
around a particular item
because maybe that's anier we
will draw in -- an area that we
will draw in.
So we get on draw which will
draw underneath the item views
before we actually draw the item
views themselves.  Which is
then followed by the items
themselves.  And then we get on
draw over which allows us a
chance to draw on top of the
item views in case that becomes
relevant in your particular
situation.  So in this case, we
are doing or just otherwise
decorating these things.
So, you need to be careful about
item digerations because it is
drawing phase might be in the
middle of several other
operations RecyclerView is
doing.  There are a lot of
things that RecyclerView does to
sort of try and present a
consistent view of the world to
adapters versus layout managers
as we are doing animations and
so on and so forth.  So the
adapter's view of the world may
not be what you're seeing on
screen right then.  So make sure
that you don't use the
ItemDecorations to access the
adapter.  Keep the necessary
information about things you
need to draw in the view holder
itself.  The ItemDecoration can
access the view holder at will
because it is data about what is
being displayed on screen right
now.
And the general rules around
drawing apply.  This is a pretty
hot code paths.
This is being called 60 frames
per second if everything is
going right.  So try not to
allocate memory to anything too
expensive.  You can go ahead and
usury cycler view get child
view holder method to get a
child view attached to the
RecyclerView at the time.  So
RecycledView Pool is important
to know about because it allows
you to pull pretty neat tricks
depending on the type of UI
you're creating.  So it normally
would be internal
implementation detail where we
are holding extra ViewHolders.
But the cool thing is you can
share it between multiple
recycler views or other custom
view Groups you have written
that need to do similar
operation that is need uniform
views of this type.
Again, always make sure that you
keep these scopes to a single
activity.  These things are
holding views.  Views hold on to
a context.  Context are
inflated with activity and you
can get yourself into trouble if
you end up leaking those
activity context by accident.
So make sure they are scoped to
a single activity at most.  You
see UIs like this in terms of
the Android lien back library
for Androidative.  You have
multiple rows, RecyclerView is
held within recycler views.  But
the inner most child items are
all of uniformed type.  We can
share the RecycledView
RecycledView Pool
across all the individual rows
and this allows us to be much,
much more efficient in terms of
how we allocate those and manage
those pools.
>> YIGIT: So, as we start
adding more functions to
RecyclerView, we try to
implement as components.  So
drag and drop.  If you look at
ListView there is a bunch of
libraryings and only some work
for your case.  So we wanted to
learn from our mistakes.  But
design item touch up we wanted
them to be independent of the
layouts.  So to use item touch
up, you can do drag and drop.
Just provide this
class -- I have a view holder,
how can I move this view holder
up and down and left and right?
You can tell us what should I
do when that item is moved so
let's say the user move it to
somewhere else and then now you
need to change that after.
Similar swipe.  The user is
swiping to the right.  So all
you have to do is tell us how
the view holder cable moved.
Tell or do what you need to
change in your adapter moved or
swiped.  So, you can drag and
drop and swipe at the same time
in the same LayoutManager T just
works.  So this is a -- flag.
In this example I say each item
can be dragged up and down and
you can swipe it towards the
end.  So it also supports RTF.
If you say and, your call base
will receive the same things
like parameters left and right.
Your call-backs will receive
left and right      right.  So
you can also customize how it is
drawn in the demos we have a
sample that you can make it fade
away as you swipe.  You just
override in the call back.  And
drag and drop or swipe yourself
maybe have a custom button
there.  I need too go faster.
Okay.  We'll go through tips and
tricks.
>> ADAM: Quickly here. So
again, as we talked about
before, we want to be for
efficient with RecyclerView
adapters than with ListView.  So
if you don't update a
particular item you don't get on
bind for that item.  We are
able to reuse that view in
place.
So, even move operations we
don't have to go back to the
adapt tore ask for that data
again because it hasn't changed.
Why should we do the extra
work?  So we don't get in
validate on that view.  We make
sure that cache works.  We have
happy kittens.  And then what
that means is a side effect is
since items can be added or
removed around it and items can
move, when you bind your views,
don't make assumptions the
position you're initially bound
for is always
going to be the position
corresponding to that data item.
Again this is a perfect
example of what can end up going
wrong.  You want to make sure
that you access the position
live from the view holder
itself.  The view holder know
what is is going on.  In this
case, there we go.  The view
holder knows what the adapter
position is right now so we make
sure to keep that updated for
you so you don't have to track
it.  Make sure you don't
accidently close over the value
of the adapter position by
accident.
>> YIGIT:
And a little mouse will not let
you do that.  So use item
change with payload.  So when
you item change like time
change, use it with payload.  It
will make your online more
efficient.  You can have better
animations.  So you can just
check if you have payloads, so
if there is no payloads -- if
there is, we guarantee the view
hold ser being reused for that
position so you don't have to
set everything.  You only set
what has changed and you hold
that information from the
payload.  It is very efficient
and great for animations.
Another mistake we see commonly
like you have a view and return
the same one -- don't do it.  If
you create new view holder.
Don't try to return the same you
have.  We
will --
Adapter versus layout positions
is something we previously
mentioned.  But a view let's say
you move that item at this
point, you can see the adapter
positions and layout positions
or some items are different
until the next layout is
calculated because now it is
calculated as a courtesy.  So
once the view system tells us to
refresh yourself, now all the
items have the same layout
position in that position.  So
that position is very -- if you
need to access your data, layout
position is good if you want to
know what is below at the point
to predict something.
>> ADAM: And that is it.
>> Thank you. Yes!
[ Applause ]
.
>> EMILY (CART captioner):
Standing by.
,
>> EMILY (CART captioner):
Standing by.  Testing, one, two,
three,.
>> EMILY (CART captioner):
Standing by
emwe
lcome t
o "how AMP
Test
APPLAUSE ]
>> Hello, I/O. My name is Addie
Osmani  ni.  You might have
heard of progressive Web apps.
It might seem like they went
from being this great idea to
now being talked about
everywhere.  It sort of e
scalated kind of quickly.
Now, for many of us in this room
, maybe you're working on an
existing app, or you're thinking
about the next app you're going
to be building.  Maybe you're
building it with a JavaScript
light Re or a framework, and
maybe you have progressive
enhancement in mind because you
want to make sure the experience
s you're crafting for many users
as possible.
We're going to keep that in mind
today.
Now, before we continue, it's
probably useful to remind
ourselves what a progressive web
app is.  So progressive Web
apps use modern Web cape
ability ies to deliver app-like
experiences.  They evolve
evolve from page in browser
tabs to tabs that exist on a u
ser's home screen and exhibit
reliable performance.
Now, this is an app called small
er pictures that I've been
working on.  It's base ically a
photo app that lets you compress
images on the go.  And it's got
features like the Web app
install banner, splash screen,
offline support.
And when I got to Mountain View,
I thought it would be useful to
test this app out.  I took a
picture of the bathroom in my
hotel.  Something I discovered
after doing this was that that b
athroom actually has a better
contribution graph than I do.
[LAUGHTER]
>>
>> You you might be
are they union       unique to
Chrome.  Often talked about in
the context of the Chrome
browser.  The answer is
absolutely not.  If you take a
look at Opera on Android, you've
seen they've got a progressive
Web app story as well.  The Web
app install banner working,
splash screen, offline support
thanks to server worker.  It's
not just them     them.  If you
take a look at Firefox
Firefox on Android as well, they
similarly got a lot of e
xplorations in this area going
on at the home screen features,
offline support, web banner b
eing experimented with at the m
oment.
When you're building a progress
ive Web app and you have p
rogressive enhancement as sort
of a core ten net     net of the
experiences you've trying to
craft, they just work for
everybody,
regardless of whether they're
on satisfy         satisfy
far             Safari on Ios,
they're trying to look at your
content from an area that might
have seriously limited connecti
vity.
When you're crafting these e
xperiences with acttures like
act
architectures, it makes sense to
be able to ship experiences f
aster for everybody.
Are progressive Web apps a
polymer only thing?  At I/O this
year we did show a first-class
experience for building progress
ive Web apps using polymer, but
you can use any tech stack to
create progressive apps.  In
fact, over the last few months,
we've seen an increase ing
number of really large apps
launched using progressive Web
app features. first one is 5
miles.  It's sort of a Pinterest
meets craigslist.  They launch
ed a full progressive Web app
with an application shell
architecture at the home screen,
splash screen.  This was built
using angular JS.  They found
their at the home screen
experience led to 30 percent
better conversions.  Similarly,
flip cart, they saw three times
more time on their site with
progressive Web app, 70 percent
conversion rate from ad users.
That's an app built using  React
.  We saw Cilio app, buying and
selling goods locally.  This is
an app built using React.  This
is universal yaiveva
JavaScript.  The progressive Web
app equals native.  The user
acquisition costs were ten times
cheaper than native.  Because
they used Web push notifications
, they saw improved user
retention and they used service
side rendering and found that
reduced bounce rates with things
like sharing posts and buying a
ds.
So today we're going to talk
about how to build progressive
Web apps using React, angular,
and ember JS.  Before we do t
hat, let's talk about waiting.
Waiting is something we all have
to do as a part of our daily
lives.  It's sort of this
frustrating thing.  You could be
at a restaurant waiting
waiting for someone to bring
you a menu or someone to bring
you your food.  And 20 or 30
minutes could easily pass by and
you're still wondering, should
I go up?  Should I ask someone
for a menu?  Ask someone in if
the food is ready?  You could be
waiting maybe an hour, two
hours.  It gets to a point where
you start questioning your life
choices and start wondering
should I just eat my wallet
instead.
On the Web, the equivalent of t
his is your users considering l
eaving your site or app, and
that's not something you want.
So the key differentiator
between the old Web and new Web
is native apps have got reliable
performance and that's
something we like to be able to
strive for with the experiences
we're shipping on the Web.  How
do we deliver native caliber
features while still being able
to use JavaScript
JavaScript libraries and
frameworks?
Well, before we talk about that,
there are a few key moments
that we need to keep in mind w
hen it comes to user experience
and performance.  The first is,
is it happening?  Time to first
paint.  Now, this is when you're
showing your user a splash
screen or a loading
loading indicator, some feedback
that indicates your navigation
has started in your page.  Next
you have time to first
meaningful paint.  This is the,
is it useful moment.  This g
enerally focuses on paints above
the full content, headline text
, something they can actually
use and find useful.
Then you've got time to first
meaningful
\interaction\intersection.
interaction.  If the user goes
tapping         tapping around
your UI, is something going to
happen?
Now, at I/O this clear, we
announce ed a new tool called
Lighthouse.  It's a Chrome
extension and a CLI that checks
that you have your progressive W
eb app features in check.
If  It also has initial support
for loading performance metrics.
Also on the slide is Web page
task.  It's a tool that's been a
round for quite some time, but b
ase ically helps you performance
profile your sites on real-
world devices with different
types of network connectivity
profiles. one metric both of
these tools look at is the speed
index.  A metric that looks at
how visually complete the page
is.  For the apps we're looking
at today, the direct, angular
apps, the targets on kale are g
oing to be a speed index of a
thousand.  Ideally things load
ing in under a second.  3G our
target is 3,000.  Under three
seconds.  On repeat view using
service worker, our goal is to
make sure we're loading thing as
close to possible.  Under a
thousand is great but as close
to zero as possible.
At I/O we're talking about
killing the offline dinosaur
dinosaur.  Ideally you
want to be able to build
experiences
experiences where you're no long
er having to play that game.
You're actually giving users s
omething valuable:  I spent too
much time on this slide and made
poor life decisions, sorry.
The service worker is the
baseline.  Runs separate from y
our page.  Response to events
like network requests and gives
you the ability to define really
well-crafted       crafted
offline experiences.
Now, service worker gives us the
opportunity really to start
rethinking our application
architectures.  One such
architecture is the application
shell architecture.  And the
idea here is that we try shipp
ing down the network as quickly
as possible.  Just look at the
content necessary to up-load a
pplication UI.  Things like the
toolbar         toolbar, drawer,
maybe some cards.  Then later
on we dine      dynamically
populate that view with your c
ontent.  This model works well
for single page applications, b
ut it's nuance ed.  You might be
working on a content-heavy site
and might be more important for
you to get actual test down to
users first.  Just keep that in
mind when evaluate ing options
when it comes to these
architectures.
But if the application shell
architecture does make sense for
your app, the way you achieve
some of these improvements in
addition to service worker is
doing things like relying on
critical path CSS.  Inline ing
the critical styles for your a
pplication shell and the
document head.  Loading in the
java      JavaScript for the
current view.  We can use things
like the A sync, and libraries
from the fillment group to be a
ble to load in the content that
we need.nd the performance wins
of such a model are actually q
uite stark.  What you'll see if
this is working, here, is on r
epeat view it's almost instant.
This is like the simplest
version of the application a
rchitecture we could come up
with.  You've got instant p
erformance for the repeat visit
compared to the first visit
where it took much, much longer.
let's talk about React.  React
is a UI library for create ing
interactive, stateful and reuse
able components built by F
acebook.  Virtual DOMs, trying
to keep your components up to
date.  It works really well on b
oth the client and server.
Now, I'm a big fan of hacker
news.  I use it every day, and I
thought, you know, maybe it
would be useful to be able to
try using Hacker News offline.
Unfortunately it doesn't work
offline on the site.  You'll get
the dinosaur if you try using
it.
By the way, this is the dinosaur
that we have over in the mobile
Web area.  You might notice
that it seems to have like four
legs for some reason and two
arms.
[LAUGHTER] I just wanted to
clarify on behalf of the Chrome
team the back two legs have been
deprecate ed but haven't been
removed just yet.
[LAUGHTER]
>> So back in 2014, hacker news
announce ed they have an open
API that anyone could go and
build a Hacker News
client with.  That was based on
Firebase.  Realtime API.  Any
time someone goes and makes a
comment, you can stream that
latest content through to your
clients.  So I decide ed to go
on GitHub and find out if
anybody had been hacking on a
really interesting hacker news
client.  I found this one by
Johnny Buchanan.  This is a
really nice client.  Lets you
take a look at all the different
views available in hacker news.
Got new comment, show, ask
jobs and it will highlight any
time a new comment is updated or
someone has edited their
comment.
Unfortunately this didn't work
offline either.  I thought it
would be kind of interesting if
you went in and
explored what it would be like
to take this complex React app
and turn it into a progressive
Web app that worked offline.
The first thing we needed to do
was make it response ive.  I
know that sounds silly but it's
quite a common thing to forget
this one step.  So we went and
optimize ed things like the
amount of view port real estate
being used on mobile.  We wanted
to make sure it actually used
up as much space as possible on
IOS and Android.  We wanted to
avoid things like overlapping
menu items.  We fixed
fixed those as well.  All of
this is just done using media
queries and nothing particularly
special.
The next thing we added was the
web app manifest.  When is this
project?  I notice ed they had a
tiny fab con.  That wasn't
going to cut it.  I redid it in
sketch and set up the Web
manifest so we could launch this
screen from the home screen and
get a splash screen.  This is w
hat the manifest looks like.  We
have a background color set for
the slash screen and another
color set for the theme color
and our icons defined in there
as well.
This application is a lot more
complex than it might initially
seem.  We have this large set of
complex realtime data being
streamed to the client and then
we have this application UI,
this skeleton, that we're using
across all of our different
views.  So we're going to split
this problem into two parts.
The first is cache ing our
application skeleton and the
next part is going to look at
content cache ing.
Now, for cache ing our
application skeleton, we're
going to use two libraries:  SW
precache, which is a build tool
that will help you precache all
of the assets you need for your
first application shell render,
and SW toolbox, which is a l
ibrary for handling all of your
dynamic views and content that
might get rendered later on.
Now, in this application, like
many React apps, we're just
using web pack behind the scenes
for a module bump link     ling
.  It can add on after the fact.
I've got some scripts set up
for this project.  SW precast
precache is another step
I run after the build is create
complete ed.  Configure ing
using a precache config file and
my pack is adjacent.  This is
what the conflict file looks
like, importing in toolbox, some
rules for runtime cache ing,
and I'm able to configure things
like what other files I might
like to have cache ed inside t
here.
In runtime cache ing I can
specify what other origins I
would like to be cache ed.  In
this case I've set it up to c
ache anything come back from
Firebase, from the Hacker News
Firebase API, and also to cache
things like Google fonts or
anything coming back from the
Google CDM. step is going and
actually registering my service
worker.  I add this boilerplate
boilerplate code to
the index file and make sure
it's registering the service w
orker generate ed by SW precache
.
I go and load up my page and l
ook at a repeat view, I can see
all of my static assets are
being serviced from the server
worker cache in dev tools.
I go into airplane mode and
check out this app and I'm happy
.  I've already opened this up
before.  I'm starting to look at
content I've seen previously,
but there's something wrong here
.  Although my application shell
consistently renders really,
really fast offline, as soon as
I close that app, I'm still in
airplane mode, I launch it from
the home screen, I get this:  No
content.  The reason for that
is Firebase's offline support is
limited to the session the user
currently has.  As soon as you
close that off and try, you know
, going and relaunching from the
home screen, you're not going t
o be able to get that same s
ession data back.  You need to a
ctually cache it a little bit
separately.
So that leads us on to content
cache ing and something I've s
pent the last four weeks trying
to solve.  So Firebase generally
, you know, because it's
realtime, it works using web
sockets.  This is just expecting
some Web socket frames in dev
schools.  You've got bits and
pieces of comment and metadata
you might use to construct
comments page.w, I first thought
maybe it would be an
interesting to store anything
that comes back here in index DB
.  Unfortunately I'd forgotten
that it's the worst API known to
man and should probably be
burned.  Luckily there exists a
number of good ab straxes for
abstractions, Dexi
by Jake Archibald.  Here we are
inside of react once again.
I'm consume ing the fair base
API the same way you would today
.  I thought maybe I could be a
little bit clever.  What if I'd
built some middleware that would
base ically positiony anything
coming back from the Firebase
API to the index and we stored
that.  Seems like a not terrible
idea, right?  Unfortunately,
what happened there is if you
went and saw any story on the t
op stories page and you opened
it up, about ten to 15 seconds
later you'd end up with three to
4,000 records.  You wait
another many, it will grow to
four or 5,000 because you're
dealing with real-time data
constantly update ing index DB
as you go.n mobile, if you open
an app where you've had a large
number of records stored because
you've been looking at lots of
pages, you want all of them to
work offline, what will happen
is in this app we had to I hadr
ate           I had
iterate over the entire
collection.  It ended up grind
ing Chrome to a halt.  That
wasn't good enough.
So I then said, okay, well,
maybe I should rethink this p
roblem a little bit.  What
What if we just used web work
ers.  I was using local forage.
I thought I'm going to batch
all of my rights for this a
pplication and only try storing
them maybe every 30 seconds
instead.  Unfortunately index DB
is still really bad when it
comes to these problems, and I
found that still wasn't good
enough for this A.
I had this revelation.  I was s
itting in an airport lounge and
I thought, well, I don't really
need this data to be entirely
fresh.  I don't need it to be
update ing every second so I
have every single comment.  I
realized that Firebase actually
has a rest API.  The rest API a
llows you to base ically go and
fetch a static version of
content from an end point and
that's something much easy ier
for to you cache.  Imagine we
have our comment page and all of
these different comments.  I
just have like JSON end points
for every single one I can go an
d cache.  That's what we do.  I
introduced an offline mode into
the react hacker        Hacker
News client       client.  I'm
still online, launched my app,
going to take a look at one of
the Google articles here.ou'll
see this is a page that has a
lot of comments, content.  We're
scrolling.  Maybe I'm on the t
ube or a bus or something, but I
want to be able to view that
content offline.  I'm going to a
irplane mode, relaunch that app.
With content cache ing in
place now using the rest API, I
can cache all of that data in
the server worker cache instead
of using just index       Index
D B.  You'll see it just works.
I can load any of the pages
I've previously visited and
they'll just work fine offline.
I ended up delaying a 300
person flight ten minutes so I
could get the pro request in for
this feature because that was
how happy I was I got this w
orking.
Now, one of the lessons there
was that I had to rethink what I
wanted my offline experience to
be.  The technical side of
getting service worker set up
and cache ing set
cache ing, that wasn't hard; it
was just crafting the right user
experience.
Next we're going to talk a
little bit about universal
rendering.  So Paul Lewis put up
these interesting graphs a few
weeks ago.  In a JavaScript base
rendering you're usually
reliant on all the script to be
downloaded            downloaded
before you can render the page.
Ends up wasting a lot of time
when the HTML arrives to give th
e user something meaningful on
the screen.  Something slightly
better is the situation where we
see a lot of frameworks moving
in at the moment.  You have a
server render with hydration
where you send a view to the
user.  The downside is you're
still rely      reliant on the
JavaScript to be loaded up
before someone can interact with
your application.  This can
result in a little bit of an
uncanny valley, where the user
sees the application but they
tap and nothing actually h
appens.
Somewhere that would be amazing
to see a lot of frameworks moved
to is this idea of progressive
rendering and bootstrap where yo
u send a functionally viable but
minimal view in HTML with your
JavaScript and ACS and it
unlocks more features as the
user starts navigating around i
t.  I'd love to see moving more
in that direction.
For the service signed rendering
portion of the react, react
router was amazing.  Worked
really well on the server.  We
found we were able to use most
routes with very little effort.
We just put together a quick
express server to get this set
up.  Some of the little lessons
I learned along the way were
make ing sure we properly guard
ed ourselves around globals.
The staff was still make ing use
of things like local and
session storage.  We had to
guard ourselves so that wouldn't
fall over.  We had to minimize
reliance on things like the DOM,
.  The previous author was u
sing the DOM to parse out the
host name so we had to switch
away from doing that.
Here's where we ended up.
Started off in a place where on
cable we had a speed index of
2,063.  By the time we'd added
service worker and service side
rendering and we used all these
content cache ing techniques
together, we got to a place
where we had a speed index of
almost a thousand.  Close to
perfect.
ow, on 3G, where it's even worse
, we're still in a pretty good
place.  We're in a place where
we started off with a speed
index of almost 4,000 and we end
up with service worker and c
ontent cache we've got a speed
of 1400.
Now, these type experiences,
this is something that I've done
over the last couple of weeks
on an existing large  React code
base.  If you're in a position
where you have something similar
and you want to turn it into a
progressive Web app, it's very
possible.  The tools are just
there.  I encourage you to try
that out.
Next up we have angular JS.
Angular is a framework that's
been around a very long time.
It tries to tackle building
complex applications, originally
focused very much around being
data first and using declare
ative HTML and data binding.
I'm going to talk about angular
too.  Before we do that, I know
there are still people that
building on angular one or have
existing legacy angular one
apps.  You might be wondering, a
lot of this progressive w
eb app stuff, great, does it
work with angular one?  Yes, but
with caveats         caveats.
So I tried building an angular
1.5 app just to demonstrate
demonstrate this.
I was trying to think of what
app I would build.  I
initial        initially thought
of building an app that would
show me the nearest places I
could go and sky dive.  Then I
realized that I don't sky dive.
The closest thing to me
skydiving is probably me zooming
in on a Google map really fast.
That's base ically the same
thing.  So I'm fine with that.
So this is the app that I built.
It's called Cherry.  This took
an hour or two.  Using angular
one.  Home screen features,
splash screen, offline support
with service worker
worker.  Unfortunately the downs
ide to this app is that it just
doesn't meet our performance
budget.  You take a look at, on
3G, where your goals are for
fast first paint is take
taking 2500 milliseconds for f
irst paint in this app.  Our sp
eed index metrics are 8,400.
That's crazy.  We shouldn't be t
ake ing so long for our users to
be able to start using this
application.
Luckily with service worker in
place we are able to slash these
numbers in half.  If you're in
a place where you can't in the
near term move over to rewriting
the application to use a modern
framework, I would consider
using service worker.  Still g
oing to get some wins but not
quite as good as something that
has support for service side
rendering and is developed with
mobile in mind.
That takes us to angular two.
It's component based, uses
directives and has an improved
dependency injection model.  The
angular mobile team have been
focusing a lot of their time
trying to make it easy ier to
build progressive Web apps using
their tooling.  We're going to
talk a little bit about that.
Now, to get started with angular
two apps a lot of the time
they'll recommend using the
angular CLI.  Does everything f
rom setting up your typescript,
boot strapping your app, using
system JS to load your app.
It's going to use that to
scaffold up a new app.
A new plague to keep in mind is
mobile.  Mobile will give you
all of this:  When you create a
new app it's going to give you a
few extra things to help you
make a progress
progressive Web app.  Going and
scaffolding you out a Web
application manifest, build
stuff to show your applications
root component and service
worker support for application
cashing.
Things at the home screen are
still possible, splash screen,
ads on home screen icons.  All o
f those are fleshed out for you.
The manifest doesn't look too
different to the manifest you
looked at today.  It's exactly
what you'd expect it to be.
Now, most of the time when we're
developing apps, we use a site
called real fab con generator
.net.  Avoids you having to hand
craft these yourself.
Next up we've got the
application shell.  By creating
a new project with the angular C
LI and mobile flag, the
application already has a build
step configured to go and
generate you an application
shell from your root component.
Here we're going to use the ma
in component that angular
created for us to create a shell
.  We're going to do something
with angular material.  Let's
say we will just add a toolbar
to this application.  We MPM in
stall the dependencies we need
for this toolbar and then we
register the toolbar inside of
our main Holo mobile component
in this case.  We see we've got
application shell directors
helping us to set up the shell.
We've got our toolbar in place.
This isn't particularly useful
yet.  We're going to go and add
in a proper toolbar in there
inside of our template.  It says
hello mobile.  So far this is
fine.  Isn't particularly excite
ing.at is excite ing is these
two little helpers.  These two
helpers are shell render and
shell no render.  Shell render
will allow you to define any UI
you want to display on the
screen before your main bundle
-- shell render displayed after
the entire application is fully
rendered out    out.  You can de
fine your application shell
dlairttively right inside of
your component.
In this case we can do things
like make sure the toolbar and a
t least a loading spinner.  That
thing we wanted to achieve for
first paint is in place and we
can use shell no render for
anything that comes after the
fact.w, the angular mobile t
oolkit comes with support for
generating a Service Worker that
will automatically cache your
assets for you.  It doesn't yet
entirely support things like
dynamic cache ing, but it does
cache ing for your static assets
.
And you can go and start using
these on serve, using the prod
flag, on build again using the p
rod flag.  I've been hacking on
a little dribble API client
called Barry using this stuff.
I found it particularly good for
that.  Offline support wasn't
difficult to get in place.
And using the CLI it was actual
ly going to scaffold you out one
of these files in the
background.  Angular Service
Worker manifest.  It contains b
ase ically all the files going
to be cashed as well as a hatch
to know Service Worker to let
you know if they're stale or
not.
What do the numbers look like?
We're going to take a look at an
angular weather app that the
team had been working on.  This
uses the application shell model
, angular CLI, a lot of the
tooling they've recently been
working on.  With Lighthouse
these are the metrics they
currently get.
First paint is about 1,083
milliseconds.  That could be b
etter.  Speed index
is 2,271.  Repeat visit is 599.
These aren't terrible numbers.
Actually pretty good.  But we
can do better.  Recently the
angular mobile team have also
been looking at offline
compilation.  Now, in angular
one, template compilation can
happen many times during your
application's life cycle.  And
angular two tries to move some
of this work into a build step,
make ing it a lot more efficient
.  So offline compilation
happens during a build step as I
said.  It no longer happens
during the browser.  We convert
things like templates into code
on the server so we don't have
to ship the compile er at all.
What this leads to in terms of
application performance is some
stark differences.  Fast first
paint is happening at 479
milliseconds.  Speed index,
almost exactly where we want it
to be.  Very close to 1,000.
And repeat visit is close to
nothing.  You're getting base
ically an instant application on
repeat visit.  Kind of awesome.
Now, we also want to take a look
at what server side rendering
would look like for these
application.  We can still
squeeze out more performance
here.  Getting your users to
first view really fast is kind
of critical these days.  Angular
universal base ically helps you
achieve this with prerenderring
on the server.  The way this w
orks is, whenever a user goes
and click on a link to your web
app, angular universal is going
to service side render the
initial response, get it to you.
A user at least has a UI in
front of them they can look at.
A couple seconds later it will
async newsily
news     nously load in the
bundle.  This is sometimes c
alled hydration.  It just means
you lead yourself to having a
pretty good perceived load time
performance overall.  Some of
the interesting things I came
across in this experience over
the last couple of weeks was
this notion of user events being
stuck in uncanny valleys is
pretty much consistent through
react, angular and ember.
Service side rendering you're
still going to end up in places
where the user can still end up
clicking, touching pieces of UI
where they're trying to have t
hings happen and be stuck until
your entire content bundle has
ended up there.
So in the angular community, gap
events is the term they use.
Things the user is going to try
accomplishing while they're
still waiting for boot strapping
to occur.  But thankfully the
angular team have been working
on a interesting solution called
pre\boot\boat that base ically
allows you to respond and p
layback events.
I'm not saying this is the
perfect solution to this problem
.  It's very interesting though.
It pht user does try
interacting with your app, as
soon as it finishes b
ootstrapping, it will replay
those events for you so they
still -- they're not having to
redo work.  Kind of interesting.
To get this set up again, we use
express.  Just import in a
ngular universal.  Doesn't take
a lot of work.  And this is what
the numbers look like.  We
start off with a speed index of
2,640 on 3G.  Once you've added
an offline compilation, Service
Worker, universal rendering,
we're down to almost nothing.
You're in a place where
universal render       rendering
and has made a huge difference.
This is very much true of the
React app we were working on
earlier as well.  Service side r
endering makes a really huge
difference.
As you can see, with Service
Worker in place again,  Repeat
visit is close to nothing.
Users are going to feel it's i
nstant.
Now, the angular mobile team are
working on make ing all of the
developer conveniences around
this stuff a lot more low f
riction.  Some of this work is
very much early on.  They're
working on improving the Service
Worker support, adding
passthrough cache ing support, a
data savings mode, make ing
sure they're looking at HV2 and
how that interacts with Service
Worker and improving the docs.
If you're working on an angular
app, go check out mobile t
oolkit.
Finally, we have ember JS.
Ember is a framework for
building ambitious Web
applications.  Utilizes
components.  Routing in Ember is
a core tenant        tenet t
here.  Similar to the react
route er works fine on both the
client and server.
Now, interestingly frameworks
have a bad rap when it comes to
performance, right?  Henrich Jor
steg, I think he was talking
about angular one and ember,
disqualify ied them for use.
This is mainly down to bundle s
ize.  Ember as a framework has a
relatively large bundle size.
The ember team acknowledge ed
this a couple months ago and
looked at how they could improve
the situation with Mobile in m
ind.  They've taken a look at
both first and repeat boot for
this problem.  On first
\boot\boat they're looking at
look
booth      boot.
On repeat they're looking at S
ervice Worker.  Also look
looking at some interesting
ideas.  String loading which
means shipping JavaScript as st
rings so you only pay the
valuation cost for modules
they're using.  And projects f
elt for streaming back features
you're not using in Ember.
I was trying to think about what
progressive app I built for
this and I came across the idea
of building a puzzle app that
would build outside when you're
complete.  Maybe not the best
idea.  Ended up on Zoope cool
blog.  This is the final thing
we ended up building for Ember.
Offline first ember application
that works instantly, meets our
performance targets, uses
service side rendering.  Works
without JavaScript enabled, by
the way.  Let's take a look at
how something like this can be
constructed.
Applications and Ember are craft
ed using the Ember CLI.  You
install it, scaffold out your
application architecture, very
basic file structure.  Go and
serve it.  Very basic app out of
the end of that.w, routes and
make ing sure your routes are
right and you have a good
routing setup will make things
like service side rendering so
much easy ier.  We make sure in
this application we've got our
routes figured out.  Base ically
got very simple routes.  One
for different categories we've
got going on.  One is by
articles four.  Off the content
for this application, actually
just exists in JSON files.  I
could be using a backen API of
some sort, just cache ing stuff
coming back from Firebase.  In
this case I have all of my data
locally.  It makes cache ing
easy ier.
This is one of our very basic
application looks like.  We've
used ember CSI, added some CSS,
using templates to load in the
content.  Nothing particularly
complex just yet.
Now, the first thing we're going
to do is add in the Web app
manifest.  Similar to the other
sites, it's not particularly
difficult.  It's something that
takes five minutes a lot of the
time.  We add this in.  This
makes sure that when the user
comes to trying to add the site
to the home screen or launch it
they're able to get home screen,
splash screen icons in place.
Next up we have Service Worker s
upport.  About a year ago the
Ember team said they'd been
watching some of Jake ash much
balanced                   Ar
Archibald.  They wanted to take
platform features and try to
make them useable for users with
stle friction as possible and a
utomate that process as much as
they can.  Ember wanted to make
this something that's free.
They're not quite yet there with
their baked-in support for
Service Worker.  The community
put together an add Ann for CLI
called broccoli Service Worker.
One of the cool things about
broccoli Service Worker, it
happens to about bel on top of
Service Worker toolbox.  That
thing we've been using for our
React app earlier on.  The
configuration for this looks a
little bit like this.  Base
ically we're inside our Ember
environment
environment.  I'm just saying I
'd like to make sure D bug
messages are enabled and the
Service Worker is enabled.  But
I can actually get control over
a lot more offline experience.
Being able to set things like
network first URL    URLs, past
include and seclude
exclude.
When dumbs to Service Worker
toolbox, you get quite a lot of
control over different network
strategies.  Able to say I'd l
ike to you go out to the network
first and then fall back to the
cache or use the cache first
and then fall back to the
network or try to race both
strategies and make sure
whichever wins actually delivers
through the content.  A lot of
flexibility there.
Once we have offline support in
place, I'm able to launch my
application in airplane mode and
view any of the content I've
previously seen.  I can go and
read articles, look at menu
items.  All of it just works
offline pretty seamlessly.
Now, next up we've got server
side rendering with fast
fastb      fastboot.  When it c
omes to server side rendering
and adding it after the fact to
a framework level application,
ember has got this just down to
an art when it comes to fastboot
.  I found this easy to set up.
It took very little
configuration.  Fastboot is a
middleware for rendering
rendering ember apps
on the server        server.
The idea is in a traditional
client side app, browser is
going to have to request a bunch
of static assets from the asset
server.  While those are load
loading, users are going to
end up having to look at a
white screen.  So the way they
solve this with fastboot is by
run    running an instance of
ember in node on the server.
When a request comes in we have
the app already warmed up in
cache and memory.  They tell the
URL you're trying to reach that
you want it rendered on the
server and send it back down.
you instale ember CLI fastboot.
The one thing I had to keep in
mind was make ing sure that
anything I'm using that's going
to be fetching data from other
origins or an API takes in mind
that you're going to be running
this code both on the client and
server.  You end up needing to
use ans IOS more     morphic.
I ended up using the fetched
data, any time I fetched it
would work fine on both the
client and server.  I end up
with this, service side renderi
ng working fine.  This is
working pretty fast on Safari
and IOS as well.  Might not have
Service Worker support yet, but
service side rendering works
fine.
One of the benefits to this is
of course that the content from
application is all just there.
I'm not waiting for any
JavaScript in order for the user
to be able to read the a
rticles.  If they're in a place
where they have limited network
connectivity, everything will
just work.
Another benefit is this works
without jaive       JavaScript
enabled as well.  You might be
wondering, great, I can read
content, but what about my user
UI?  I spent a little bit of
time recrafting the drawer menu
for this application entirely in
CSS, and that just means that
my user is able to use some UI
with the content in place, even
if my JavaScript bundle is still
loading with the rest of the
framework.
And then we've got a little bit
of final performance
optimization to squeeze as much
as we can out at the very end.
This is what our index looks
like for this application
application.  It's u
sing some template helpers.e of
the things I want to add is
critical path CSS we talked a
bout earlier for the application
shell.
We install an add-on called
imperC       ember CLI content.
We can figure that in the build
.  For this application it's not
got a lot of styles.  I don't
need to do anything special to
get my critical path CSS.  I'm
going to inline the entire style
sheet inside my document head.
Finally we've got that one
problem of large framework still
being large frameworks.
Unfortunately this is something
the frameworks still have to
solve on their own.   Embore
before UGs a bit is almost 700
bill bites                700
kill bites in size.  I don't
want that to block rendering.  I
would have myvendor script as
well as the main application
code for my app.  But in this
case I'm probably going to have
to use something like defer
because ember can't make scripts
for you by default.  We've got
things like J something inside
the application.
Also something we can take care
of.  Allows script fob
downloaded without blocking the
page.  Defer claims to do the
same thing except it's supposed
to guarantee script execution
order.  The spec says that it
should be download
downloading all of your scripts
together and execute ing them
before DOM content loaded.
Unfortunately in some other
browsers that's not exactly the
case.  In IE less than ten.  It
might execute your second script
halfway through the execution o
f your first script.  Yea
browsers.  But we're still going
to use defer in this case to
avoid blocking.
But at the very end of all of
this, so we've got service side
rendering in place, Service
Worker in place as well.  We've
taken speed index of almost
3,000, trimmed it down with s
ervice side rendering
rendering using fast food,
trimmed it down with the
optimizations we've made even
further.  In repeat visit it's c
lose to instant, close to
nothing.
Now, I'm really excite ed about
the ember team exploring how to
bake in these ideas directly
into the CLI.  I'm also excite e
xcite ed about the angular team
doing this and really excite ed
about the react community
embracing Service Worker as a
core tenet
in the applications we're
building there as well.
So three take aways for today
are:  Do less and be lazy
lazy.  If you're going to be
trying to ship bytes down to
your users, try to ship the thin
nest, smallest bundle possible.
This will benefit absolutely
everyone.  And be lazy just
means lazy ily load in
everything else that you need a
fter the fact.
Design for constrained envir
onments.  You know, a lot of the
time we're building things
these days, we're testing things
out on high-end phones or
computers.  A lot of our users
aren't going to have that.
They're not going to have a
perfect Internet connection all
the time.  They're going to be
in places where they'll have
limited connectivity, maybe
using devices that are like CPU
bound or aren't as powerful as
things we're testing on.
If you're developing with c
onstrained environments in mind,
you're going to be able though
ship experience that is benefit
everyone, hopefully lead to
performance improvements there.
And go for progressive.  Because
now is a good time.  Looking at
all the frameworks and
libraries we've been looking at
today, all of them are exploring
things like server side r
endering.  All of them have got
the ability to use Service
Worker as a first class citizen
and have it work well and lead
to performance improvements,
have it lead to reliable
performance.  That thing we're t
rying to hit with the rest of
Web apps.  Everything else, from
like setting up your Web app
manifest and so on, that stuff
is still quite trivial to do.
And it's not to say that instant
application
applications with things I've
shown you today are the end; i
t's really just the beginning.
There's still a bit of work we
have to do on both the jaive
JavaScript engine and
framework side when it comes to
performance after the fact.
I've been focusing on load
performance a lot today.
There's stale lot we can do
after the fact so when your user
is interacting with the app it
still stays instant after that.
So please go check out our new
progressive Web app page or our
Web fundamentals.  I hope this
has been useful.  Thank you.
[
APPLAUSE ]
2 p.m....
MW5 - How AMP Achieves its
Speed 2 p.m.
[ Applause ]
>> MALTE: Hi, everyone. My name
is Malte and I'm the tech lead
for Google.  That means that I
kind of manage the team that
works full-time on the open
source project for Google and I
kinda also wrote some of the
code, I guess.  Which is
important because we want to
dive into how it works today and
how it achieves the speed.  So
even if ample might not be for
you because you're working on an
online batching app or
whatever, you can take advantage
of the techniques we use and
make your own thing way faster
than it might be right now.  So
I said AMP, it sands for
accelerated pages       pages
and I'm never going to say it
again, now you know what it
means.  It's about super fast
content on the Web.  Now AMS an
open source project launched
inside Google in our search
engine, which most of you
probably used every so often.
And we have this carousel here.
It just boom goes up.  So load
times are way, way faster than
we see on the normal Web.  And
you can swipe the results and
that's something you dock with
an every day Web page.  So that
is AMP.  You can go to your
browser and switch
for something you see and you
should see these AMP results.
So, AMS pretty fast but we
haven't talked that much about
how fast it is.  And frankly we
didn't know.  It was an
experiment but it's been out
there for a while now.  This is
what we sorry across all traffic
where Google Search is leading
to AMP results.  Sowed meetian
load time is under one second.
The exact number is 711.  It is
pretty substantially under one
second.  Which if yow heard
about rail and that is like
really where you want to be.
But, one important part of
performance optimization is that
you can't only look at your
median user.  That is important
because 50% have a better
experience and 50% are worse.
So what we typically do is look
at the percentile of users that
have a really bad Internet
connection loading the biggest
Web page.  And so for them, we
are still seeing load times
faster than 8 seconds.  Which
might seem slow and I find slow
and I'm not happy with, but if
you look at the control group of
similar pages that are not AMP,
they have average load time of
22 seconds.  So the 1% worst AMP
loads are still much better
than the average non--AMP loads.
Which I think it is pretty
exciting.  And all of this, like
the one second that we see at
the median is obviously not
instant but for a technique that
I'm going explain today, called
pre-rendering, you go from fast
to instant.
A number we mentioned yesterday
is there is quite some momentum
around AMP.  And so looking at
Google Search index, there is a
crazy number of 125 million Docs
and growing every day.  And
obviously this could be like
only Wikipedia but what I find
more exciting and pretty
humbling is that there is
apparently 640,000 Web pages
already different domains who in
some form or another
implemented AMP.  Which is
really cool.  And it's Earl I.
It's an open source project and
we are shipping new releases
every week.  Very recently we
finally supported menus which I
agree is an important feature.
We are working on Forms and
supporting all kinds of features
like pretty advanced like fly
and side templating.
On the next slide, this is my
favorite technology aboutasm.
Look at this.  The average
mobile site in the back.  It's
not winning.  And what I find
important to emphasize is that
if you're pan tuning your site,
you are going to win this race.
AMP is not about winning this
race but AMP is about being up
there in front.  And more
importantly, all AMP pages are
pretty uniformly up there in
front.
And I think if there is anything
seek ressauce to how this works
-- secret sauce -- it probably
my answer
is going to be the AMP
validator.  This is how this
really looks.  So you can go to
every page and add development
equals 1 to the UR R and you
will get these error messages or
hopefully none.  But they are
just like compiling errors.
Because we are developers and we
are used to this, like for us
it's like a to-do list.  We are
like cool.  I'm just going to
fix them.
That is awesome.  The other
affect this has and I might just
speak from personal opinion,
that sometimes you might like
have some disagreements about
what the right thing to do is
and so, in this case, the AMP
validator can say that's not a
good idea.  So going from the
basic stuff, let's go into how
AMP works.
So we developed this new
rendering engine for documents
which no, we did not because why
would you?  I think it's
amazing we are in 2016 and all
these browser and they are all
great.  And looking back 10
years that was not the case.  So
I think we are in exciting
times for development.  You
don't really have to wor I about
browsers anymore.  And so AMPs
are just Web pages.  They don't
have a special rendering engine.
Just Web pages.  And that is
why everything that AMP is doing
internal tow gain performance
is equally applicable to all
non--AMP Web pages.
Diving into what is going on
there, I want to talk about
front loading.  And I have to
tell you a secret.  And I hope
my friend from the Chrome team
aren't mad about me but here it
is.  Browsers really hate Web
fonts.  By the way this is my
son and he is extremely
unimpressed with like the Web in
general.  You'll see throughout
this presentation.  So here is
what is going on.  That is why
I'm saying they hate Web fonts.
Apparently, developers
sometimes put like font face
annotations in their CSS that
they don't really use on their
page.  The browser really is
careful about downloading fonts.
What they do is look at your CSS
and then they look at all the
other CSS and then look at your
JavaScript and then apply the
styles to the page.  And at the
very moment where they like
could have rendered the page,
they go, okay, I'm going to
network and fetch the font.  And
Chrome, and FireFox will wait
three seconds, Safari will wait
forever.  So the font is
entirely in the critical path of
rendering your page.  So
getting that optimized is
extremely critical for good Web
performance.
Summarizing all your style
Sheets and all your synchronous
strips that are in the hat
block, font, download.  In code
that means if you have a script
source or style sheet, those
will slow down fonts from even
being started to put on the
network.
Now, AMP has certain rules about
how it likes HTML to look and
for this reason, what we say is,
you can have style Sheets but
they have to be in line in the
style type.  And yes, they can
be script text but they do need
to have the attributes which
then takes it out of the
critical path and browser will
happily try to render the page
and they'll have the fonts.  The
result of that is that AMP can
having downloaded the document,
which is important for rendering
it, initiate the HTP request
for the fonts with zero HTP
request in the critical path
which is a big improvement for
performance.
So there is a problem, though.
And that is why this slide
exists.  This slide is trumped
down.  It looks much, much worse
in reality because there is
window prefixes going on.  So
every AMP document contains this
bit of foil page.  While I
think it is pretty cool
technique, it has some problems.
What is going on?  Because of
the strip tags have the acing
attributes, some of them are
actually needed to render the
page, you would get incomplete
render early in the life cycle
which looks not very good.
And so, one common technique to
avoid that is to manually hide
the page by saying, for example,
visibility hidden, and then
when the script loads, say okay,
now it is visible.  So while
that works, it has one important
downside.  If for example your
network fails that the
millisecond and that strip never
downloads, it could happen that
the page stays completely blank
because it says it should be
blank.  And that is why I think
this is such a brilliant idea
which came from like some person
commenting on a GitHub issue.
Why don't you use a CSS
animation as a time load
mechanism?  So what is going on
here is that AMP will go and
after eight seconds, show the
page if the JavaScript fails to
load.  So typically the
JavaScript is much, much faster
and very likely could be
attached so you would never
reach that but it is very
important that you have this
extra robustness for the page
will eventually show if there is
no JavaScript.
Great.  So with that, I want to
talk about my favorite topic
which is static but responsive
layout.  So, for this, I'm going
to show you a little video and
I'm going ask you to read the
text.
Please read me -- this is a
nowing when an
element -- - annoying -- when I
was first thinking about AMP, I
had this one idea that this is
really the worst thing on the
Internet.  And if I would do
anything at all, in AMP, I would
make it so just this would
never ever happen.  And now I'm
going explain to you why it
can't happen.  And it's again
pretty simple.  So in AMP, every
single element has to have its
size defined in the mark up and
it is much easier to see what
that means in code.  So if you
use this Web component called
AMP-image to look at images, and
you can lease out the width and
height, it is mandatory on this
Web component.  What will
happen in a browser is when it
has an image tag and no height
on it, it will say it is
probably zero pixel high and
then it will fetch it and then
go it's not zero pixel high.
Why would an image be zero pixel
high and then everything moves
down.  So what is mandatory with
the height, a browser can put a
box and then fill it in when it
is time to have the image back
from the network.
Now with this requirement of put
the width and height and source
cold, how does this work
together with responsive design
and I want to emphasize that AMP
is from the ground up designed
with responsive design in mind.
Here is the answer.  And that
is a great example of how Web
components can be really, really
nice in Web developments.  All
you do is put layout equals
responsive on the element and
what AMB will do, it will say
thank you for the width and
height, I'm going to use that to
populate the aspect ratio and
size the image to the available
space horizontally and make the
height based on the aspect
ratio.
So, coming from this, there are
those situations where you can't
predict the size.  Again this
is also a nice example of the
collaboration on the open source
project where I initially was
like, you're out of luck.  You
can't do anything.  And then
publishers were, sometimes we do
kind of need to resize things
so we gave in and came up with a
pretty good model to make it
work nonetheless.
So when AMP thinks about a page,
it considers things based on
where they are relative to the
position of the viewport.  The
view sport what you currently
see.  So if you already scrolled
down, some stuff above and
there is always probably if a
page is longer than the
viewport, there will be
something below.  And so, if
something is below the viewport
and it says I would like to be
bigger than originally planned,
then AMP says that is cool
because that can't really affect
what is in the viewport.
Similarly, but slightly more
nifty, if it's above the
viewport, you can still allow
resizing because you can know
how the height changed and you
can just subtract that from
scroll top and end up having
everything in viewport staying
in the same spot as before.
But finally we come to stuff
that is currently in viewport
and there AMS pretty
opinionated, you can not resize
it.  That is until user actually
interacted with that element.
So, what you can do for example,
if you need to resize, AMP will
say no, but you can show a
little button to say like, allow
resize and then AMP will say,
user agreed that is fine and
from that moment on that thing
can change little size however
it wants.
Great so from that I want to
talk about the next topic.  So,
AMP is designed so it knows very
little like about how to do
anything.  It can load images
and simple videos and text
obviously but that is about it.
And for everything else there
is extensions which are just Web
components you load.  Think
about Tweets, Instagrams,
YouTube videos all kinds of
stuff.  There is dozens of them.
So to load them put the script
tag on your page.  It has the
same attribute so that it
doesn't block your page and then
you put this in this case,
AMP-YouTube tag on your page.
It has to be width and height
which is pretty typical for a
video typically.  And then but
the thing with Web components
is, when the browser sees this
like AMP does YouTube and hasn't
learned what it means, it will
go, HMMM, let's draw it like a
spam.  I don't know what width
and height means.  Let's make it
in-line element.  And that is
not the best default and it
leads to the same kind of affect
of the page jumping around.
And it is so bad that from is
even a name for it.  So the
flash of unstyle Web components.
And there is several ways how
to work around it.  The easiest
way is to just wait for the
extensions to load.  That will
be similar to a technique we are
using to wait for the main
script to load which is the
visibility hidden and visible
thing I explained.
But, we want to do better.
Because some more complex pages
might have 10 extensions and now
you have to make a request to
finish for something to be
shown.  They pile up.  So
instead, AMP can render the page
before all extensions are
loaded and here is how it works.
So, the core AMP JavaScript
library, the one that is
blocking page layout, it knows
how to layout elements even
though it has no videos.  So it
goes and says, I
actually know what widthing and
height means and what layout
responsive means and what fixed
height means and it will draw a
box.  It's not actually great
but it can make it CSS obviously
and then eventually, that
YouTube extension downloads and
then that YouTube extension will
say fill in that box.  And that
is a load behavior that we are
all used to because that is how
images usually load on they and
people perceive it as a decent
experience.
So to summarize, in AMP, the
extension siding is independent
from their implementation.  So
you don't have to know what
YouTube is to make a box for,
tube video.  The extension
loaded with a script so they
don't block anything.  The box
is reserved immediately and then
filled with content when the
extension loads.
Coming from this pretty
AMP-specific thing, I want to
come to a topic that is really
applicable to every single Web
app out there.  And that is
mutation fetching.  There is a
simple rule that everyone should
follow.  You shouldn't
interleaf reading and writing to
the DOM.  Unfortunately, it is
really hard to do this in
practice.  Here is a contrived
but not that unrealistic example
of about how to do this.  So,
your code might say win doe
something.  Besides that it
would set the height of
something and it will say, how
high are you?  And then you say
like this other thing has to be
sides as well and what is your
height?  Right?  So, this you
might not write code looic this
but if you have a team of more
than one person and there is
more than one thing on the page
going on you're getting into a
situation where in each
animation frame you might do
various operations that are
acting on various parts of a
page.  And it comes with a big
problem.  Which is that browsers
when you read from the DO.
And say like what is your
height?  Or what is your width?
Or any of these like things
that require laying out the
page, they trigger recall
declaration of style which means
that how does the CSS affect
the page layout on the DOM
elements -- recall declaration
-- and so that triggers the
style application and if you
want to make an application that
runs at 60 frames per second,
you might be able to afford two
of those even though you really
shouldn't but at 3 your mobile
device will pass out and say I'm
beginning to jinx the hell out
of this.  Fortunately there is a
very easy waway to make this
better.  Which is it to
absolutely change the order in
which operations are executed.
So like here, if you first do
all the rights, and then you do
all the reads for the DOM, there
is exactly one style
calculation triggered and as you
can see, it's pretty easy to
match unlimited number of
operations.  It's really hard to
manually write an application
that is larger than one file to
adhere to such a strict rule.
So that is why there are helpful
libraries that make it easy.
If you are ever looking at the
AMP source code, it has a
library and it says, I'm going
to execute all the measures and
then I'll execute all the mew
talks and there is a popular
library called FastDOM that does
a similar thing and it really
helps withizey API to make the
DOM operations execute in ideal
order.
With that I want to move to the
next topic which is Analytics.
So obviously Analytics is really
important like you want to know
how many people come to your
app, what they are doing, where
are they clicking, how much time
they spend and how they scroll
and that is really great but
what happens is sometimes more
of them come in and I have this
like, went through this myself
where you like talk to the sales
person from a vendor and they
say like we have this awesome
new metric and I'm like, yes!
So we are -- and you realize a
new vendor like that is one
thing you always reported to
your mother-in-law slightly
dipped.  And then you realize
users there is not less users,
it's just that that new vendor
terps that metric different so
you panic and put the whole
thing back in.  So in practice,
that happens all the time and so
we are seeing Sites that have
like 5, 10, 15 of these.  And it
turns out that basically too
much of everything is really bad
for performance.  However, we
challenge ourselves thinking
there is really very the you can
do about this being a problem
so would there be a way to have
both?  So essentially,
all-you-can-eat Analytics and
still have good performance.
And the solution that seems
relatively obvious in retrospect
is to separate instrumentation
from reporting.  So in AMP, the
instrumentation so the thing
that measures your scroll
progress, that measures clicks,
exists only once and it is built
into AMP and then it can report
stuff so however many times you
as a developer choose.  So,
basically what is the deal is
that AMP knows how to talk to
major Analytics vendors and then
just basically pings them and
says user scrolled and they
interpret that information.  And
if you have for example
in-house Analytics or AMP
doesn't directly support your
favorite vendor, add config
yourself.  This is how it looks
on the open source project.  So
just randomly chose this and
this describes how to create a
request when you track a
picture.  There is just a rule
saying use this and then put
this stuff on the back.  And so,
basically it's just a
configuration that says given an
event, how to construct a URL
so that score tracks that as a
page view and this file is long
and for every major vendor has a
small rule set and that is how
you can like talk to them all
but only pay the costs of
figuring out when you need to
talk to them exactly once.
With that, from Analytics I want
to go to the final topic and it
is slightly different bauds it
doesn't necessarily apply to the
general Web.  That is instant
loading.  As already like I
talked about very quickly at the
beginning, instant loading is
achieved through pre-rendering.
And pre-rendering means that
you render something before the
user said I want to go there.
So, on a Google Search result
that would mean we think they
probably click on the first
result.  It's not the worst
guess.  So let's render it
already.  And that obviously
comes to some problems, right?
Because the user might not go
there but now you already used
that bandwidth and that CPU and
the mobile CPU means battery and
that RAM to render the page and
that could be problematic.  And
it was in fact that so
problematic that the native
version of rendering, is
essentially unusable on mobile.
Now, to solve this problem we
went through a series of
insights that led us from it
being essentially impossible to
working really well.  And the
first insight which is by the
way the most important insight
when you think about performance
optimizations in general, is
that humans are kind of slow.
And I mean that in the best
possible way.  So our reaction
time is in the order of two
seconds.  So, from that you can
say in order to appear instant,
you only have to appear instant.
You don't have to be actually
be all the way done.  And here
is what that means in practice.
So this is a typical website,
right?  It's not.  Because this
is a typical website.  It's
really long.
But, for something to appear as
having loaded instantly, the
only thing that is really
important is that the thing that
I see when I go to the page is
already done.  Everything else
because reaction time is like, I
can start downloading all the
other images for example, that
instant where I show the page,
where the user clicks it.  What
AMP does. when it is in
prerender mode, it will say any
resource that isn't visible by
the user, the instant the page
is shown to them, will not be
downloaded at all during
prerender mode.  So that saves
all the bandwidth that is --
wouldn't have been necessary in
a case where the user never goes
to that page.  It's typical for
a page to maybe have like one
image or two images in the first
report but overall the pages
have many, many more images so
not downloading them saves a lot
of bandwidth.  That leaves the
harder problem, which is CP.
And RAM usage on mobile.  Which
is a big, big problem.
And in AMP,
it is relatively well optimized
so we are pretty confident that
CPU usage of AMP itself is
okay.  But loading all these
bits, so it might be YouTube
videos Instagrams, et cetera.
So first of all AMP doesn't
control them and to be honest,
some of them do a lot of CPU.
And for this reason, AMP does
this.  That was all the way
clear?  I can do it again.  So
when AMP prerenders a document,
it will not actually load any of
the extensions implementation.
So in the YouTube case you can
do really well because you can
guess the post URLs.  So it will
put a poster on the page so it
looks complete but the expensive
part, the YouTube iframe that
loads JavaScript isn't actually
loaded.  So when the user then
expresses intent that they want
to go to the page, AML go and
say, we'll load the YouTube
iframe because they might want
to watch the video.  But the
page looks pretty complete and
so that user gets it
gratification that everything is
done even though in fact not
everything is done.
And so with this leaves two
techniques, only loading stuff
that is actually visible and
only loading stuff we know the
CP.
And RAM use sage relatively
minimal.  You get the capability
to prerender pages on mobile
where it is really feasible with
a general Web page.
So again, like you have seen
initially with the development
equals 1.  Put a fragment
parameter
on anymore document.  Try this
in a browser and say prerender
equals one.  And that puts any
AMP document in prerender mode.
And you'll see
it's not useful for yourself
because there won't be images
loaded that aren't in the
initial viewport.  So scroll
down and nothing loads.  Same
thing with other things.  The
page as far as first viewport
goes, looks very complete.  And
then there is a message API
where you can tell the page
you're now being shown to a
person.  Go loadering else.
And that together gets that --
that is how Google Search work.
So it would load an iframe and
tell tell you're in prerender
and then when the user clicks it
send a post message saying
you're being shown.  Go crazy
loading everything you need.
And with that, that was kind of
all I wanted to talk about in
terms of optimization.  I wrote
this blog post a while ago.  And
I do have the URL again at the
end which goes through the
entire list of optimizations
that all AMP page vs. and I like
to say they can't not have it
because
AMP guarantees it.  But can be
used as a nice resource all the
things that might apply to a
non-AMP Web page.  Still I
personally am very impatient and
I'm not satisfied at all with
the speed of AMP.  So, what is
your favorite AMP site?
The it's still too slow.  It
might use an extension that is
not very optimized or you might
find that you find some case
where did is slow.  That is the
most exciting thing about AMP
which is that you can help.  As
an open source project, send a
request and we are shipping
every week.  So, I think it is
pretty amazing that you have
this level of impact because
every AMP page runs the latest
version.  So if you send a page
to AM.  And saw it was like
460,000 domains using it, a week
later, they will all run your
poll request.  So make a big
difference and what I like to
say is that this has been
working so far.  And we really
want to thank all of you for
sending these contributions.
So, AMP wanted to GitHub last
October and we so far got tone
1,954 requests.  But what is
even nice ser that it comes from
160 different contributors.
So, I have a team, not 160, not
even close.  So it has been a
really, really cool
collaborative effort and again
thank you all because we
wouldn't have been able to do it
without you.
A few more things in terms of
bookkeeping because I really
want to point to this.  It's not
a book but I thought it was
funny.  So this website called
AMP by example.com and so I
personally I know JavaScript,
not the best Web developer and
this is just like examples for
all the things you might do in
AMP and it is like output and
the source code and copy paste
yourself to happiness.  It's
really useful if you want to get
started with AMP.  Another
shout out is that Google
yesterday launched an AMI called
the
AMPURLAPI.
This is applicable to you if you
have either a Web app or native
app that has links and you
might want to say it is good for
all users if we pointed them to
the A MP version of those URLs.
So you can say hey, is there
an A MP version for this and
they will say yes or no.
Coming from this it was first
shown yesterday and it's a topic
I'm super excited about.  So,
my talk is almost over.  I would
ask all of you to go to the
theater after this 3 p.m. where
Alex will talk about how AMP
relates to progressive WebEx.
And they work really well
together.  A nice demo yesterday
in the "Washington Post" which
totally impressed me.  Anyway,
that is all I have.  Here is the
link to our Docs.  Our GitHub,
and again the blog posts.  Thank
you very much.
[ Applause ]
FB22 - 5 Neat Mobile
Development Tricks with Google
3PM
3PM.
>> TODD: Hi, everybody. We got
-- hi, everybody!
Wow!
Like last section on the last
day and we still have people
that are awake.
Congratulations.  We made it to
the last session on the last day
of the conference.  I don't
know about you, but I kind of
feel like this guy.  Maybe you
feel like this guy too maybe
because your brain is full or
you partied too hard last night
or like me, you woke up at 4:00
in the morning and couldn't go
back to sleep.  Either way,
congratulations.  Thank you for
being awake and alert and a good
audience.  I already can tell,
you're going to be a great
audience.  So let's talk about
Firebase.  As you may have
heard, Firebase is aviette of
integrated products designed to
help you earn money.  Maybe we
mentioned that before.  And we
have been calling it a suite but
for a lot of these talks I feel
like we generally have been
talking about features in
isolation and for this session
what I'd like to do is show you
some of the cool tricks that you
can do when have the various
features of the new Firebase
platform working together in a
few hypothetical scenarios and 5
neat tricks you can do with the
new Firebase platform.  Let's
look at those now.  #trick
Number 1.  I'm with the band or
Dynamic Links plus -- equals
notification goodness.  Let's
start off by talking about our
brand new ticket app, ticket
picker.  The hot new way for you
to get tickets on certain
baseball games.  And they
decided as a good market ploy to
draw users in, they will set up
a companion site where you can
read news and gossip and get
tour dates about your favorite
bands and sort of a way to draw
people in to draw people in,
they will add a nice button that
says, if you're interested in
getting tickets for the rolling
stones, then click on this
button and try out our app.  By
the way, I'd like to point out
that is difficult to draw a
scope.  I then just looks like a
sad pancake but that is why I'm
a Developer Advocate not an
artist.
So this sounds like a situation
for Dynamic Links.  If you know
what Firebase Dynamic Links are,
they are mobile deep links that
work the way you want them to.
With one link that we can put
on our site, we can either take
the user to the iOS or the
Android version of their app if
they have it in signaled and if
they don't have it installed, we
can take them to the app or
play store and if the user had
to install our app first,
Firebase Dynamic Links can
retrieve that original Lincoln
text and remember what link user
clicked on to get them into the
app in the first place so we
can deliver the user a first
time experience that is relevant
to the link they clinked on.
So rather than showing a boring
homepage, we know they installed
our app because they are
interested in the rolling cones
and maybe we can show them
information that is relevant
that way.  So the link to try
out to get into our app would
look a little like this.
And I can break it down for you
if you're not familiar with
Dynamic Links and you probably
aren't.  First we added these
entries for the appropriate play
and App Store IDs as well as
your iOS bundle identifier.
This lets us know which place in
the play store or App Store to
redirect the user if they don't
have the app installed.  We also
will add in these UTM tracking
tags and if you don't know what
they are, they are sort of
hierarchal way of representing
any kind of marketing campaign.
So you have got like your Uber
spring 2016 campaign and then
within that, you have your
various sources, like the
companion website or maybe an
e-mail blast and that sort of
thing and various content and
medium.  You can break it down
in different ways.
And all that information will
get captured in Firebase
Analytics when the user clicks
on this Deeplink.  And then we
have the link parameter itself
and this is the information that
gets passed into your app when
it first opens up.  And in this
case, we are deciding that we
are going to capture the band
that the user was browsing when
they decided to click on this
link.  So, we know that the
featured band here happens to be
the rolling cones and that will
be able to realize when we
process this URL.  So by
analyzing this link information,
we first opened the app instead
of our sign in page, our app
can analyze that link parameter
and say the user was interested
in our app because they were
looking at a page for the
rolling cones so maybe we should
show them relevant info and
then we show a bunch of dates
when they first open our app
instead of that sign in screen.
This is important.  The user
said I'm willing to go ahead and
install your app because I'm
super interested in this data.
So why not make sure they can
get that data they are
interested in right away?  And
so this is dynamics and maybe
you been this.  But we also do a
lot more with this link and
knowing what that featured band
was.  For instance, our app can
automatically subscribe the user
to the rolling scopes Firebase
Cloud Messaging topic.  If you
want to know what topics are,
they are ad-hoc Groups that any
client can subscribe to on the
Cloud Messaging server.  So
basically we can tell the Cloud
Messaging server, send this
message to any client that
subscribed themselves to this
topic, rolling cones orb any
other band.  Firebase Cloud
Messaging kept track of which
clients subscribed themselves to
that topic and it can send the
inform to all the devices
without your having to keep
track if it on your server
somewhere.  So when the rolling
cones decide we are going to
make new ticket sales available,
you can schedule a future
message through Firebase
Notifications.  You can see here
that in addition to sending a
message we can scheduling a
message to be sent at a
particular time.  And schedule
messages in a specific time
zone because tickets are going
on sale 9 a.m. all across the
world globally.    We can ma
make sure that notification gets
sent out globally so everyone
has a chance to get tickets
before they sell out.  And then
we are sending this set of
Notifications to devices that
have subscribed to the rolling
cones topic and then we can also
capture conversion even here.
So, various events in Firebase
Analytics that are important to
your app like being able to
purchase a ticket, you can tell
by these Analytics, let's make
these one version events that we
really care about.
And then so you can track
whether a notification has led a
user to complete one of these
events.  And this is really
important for daughter-in-lawing
whether your Notifications are
being -- important for knowing
spammy.  If very few people are
opening them and not completing
a ticket purchase, maybe it's
spammy.  If you targeted your
Notifications correctly, then
the percentage of people who get
the notification open it and
then go ahead and complete a
purchase will be much higher and
that is a good way of judging
whether or not these
notifications are effective.
And this in coming band is also
seems like a pretty good
starting value for a user
property of like the
user's favorite band.  Maybe we
can change that on the app
later.
This seems like a good starting
point and then we can do a lot
of floaters Firebase Analytics
based on the favorite fans bands
of our users like the number of
people who said, yes, I'm
interestedded in reviewing this
app and we can facility they're
by various user properties
included their favorite band so
we can see for everybody who
listed the rolling cones as
their favorite band, how many of
them decided they were okay
reviewing my app?  So we can get
a better idea of how these
different bands of different
bands behave and if we say we
really need more people
reviewing our app and it turns
out that bands or the rolling
cones are more likely to review
our app than fans of W2, we can
figure that out in Firebase
Analytics.
And then because we used all of
these UTM tags to record all the
Deeplink info, we can evaluate
the performance of the companion
site.  We can look at all of
the companion site users and see
how they behave not just did
they click on these links to get
into our app but are they more
or less likely to perform these
important conversion actions
like buying a ticket, like
subscribing to our newsletter,
like signing up for premium
service like sharing the app
with our friends.  So when the
CEO says we seem to be spending
a lot of money on this companion
site, we can say yes, it is
getting us users which we know,
but we can also decide it's
getting us users that are
valuable to us because they are
buying tickets or sending the
app to their friends.  And maybe
it's because that nice Deeplink
experience is giving them a
better experience and they are
more interested in our app in
the first place.  That say lot
you can do by adding in one
Dynamic Link to your banners.
I'm going to move to trick
number 2.  Birds of a feather.O
Firebase authentication plus the
Realtime Database plus Storage
equals some group photo sharing.
This one gets into some crazy
rules here but stick with me.
So this is our fun bird watching
app, birdie hunt.  They decided
they will add a new feature for
users to be able to share
photos of birds they found with
the public.  Like I found a good
pick of a chickadee and I say
everybody check out this
picture.  And so, clearly in
seems like a good use case for
Firebase Storage.  A place where
we can store all of our photos
in the Cloud.  That is what it
was made for storing large data.
People used to like base 64 in
this data and stick it in the
Realtime Database now.  Guilty.
This is way better.  Now when
we do that, when we basically
add a -- up load a file to
Storage, in the completion
handler what you'll get back is
metadata and among that metadata
one of the most important
things is a download URL to the
a file you uploaded.  The U are.
L of the file plus tokens.
But this is what you're going to
have to be able to download
that photo.
And then we can store these URLs
in the database.  We can create
an album photos object and
create a different object for
each different album and within
there create photos with the
name and URL and just like that,
people can see our photo
albums.  Which sounds great but
it turns out I didn't know this,
bird watching Groups are very
cutthroat and competitive.  They
didn't want other Groups to see
the photos they took.  They
only wanted to share with other
people in their bird watching
group.  Who knew?  We can still
do that.  Partly by taking
advantage of Firebase sign in
which allows you to sign in your
user from a number of different
providers.  We have Google and
Facebook and Twitter and GitHub
as well as letting you use your
own e-mail and password and you
don't have to deal with storing
passwords on your end.  When we
use Firebase auth, we get back a
unique ID no matter how they
signed in.  You get beck a
consistent Firebase user object
that has a unique ID that you
won't have name collisions
across the different sign in
providers which is nice.  Now
take that and store basically
the Members who can view the
various albums in our album
members and ID sections.  We can
stick our various user IDs into
this object and maybe list some
administration rules.  Some
people are owners and some are
editors and some are viewers.
Once we get that in there, now
we need to write some rules.  We
need to tell the near base
database, for someone to see
this photo here, their user ID
must exist in the corresponding
album object.  Does that make
sense?
So how do we do that?  We do
that with these rules, which I
know look complicated at first
but if you break it down, you
can see basically we are just
going up the tree a little bit.
We are saying for any object in
the album photos object, so to
go up the tree a little bit and
go down and find the
corresponding album members
object N there, if there is a
child that has the same user ID
as the user who is currently
signed in, then they are allowed
to read this album and if it
turns out the value of that
object happens to be editor
owner then they are allowed to
write into this album and that
is basically all we are saying
here with this code.  But wait,
how do we know how to put those
user IDs in there in the first
place?  We can actually have
rules for that as well.
Let's say we want to have a way
for members on to request they
join a particular album.  I say
I would looic to view this
album, please let me in.  We can
create an album joiner's object
where people add in their own
user ID to make requests and
then the owner of any particular
album has the power to remove
people from the album and put
them into the album members
object.  So let's look at the
rules needed to do that.  First
we need to say that anybody can
add their own user ID to a
joiner's object.  It is just
request to join and anyone can
do that.  Doesn't mean they'll
get approved but anyone can.  So
we would do that with this
rule.  Basically within album
joiners for any arbitrary album,
for any arbitrary user ID you
can write your own user ID.
That is all we are saying here.
Next up we need to say that
anybody -- basically we can say
that if you want to alter
anything, besides the process of
writing your own user ID, you
need to be the album owner.  So
we do that using this same sort
of let's go up the tree and then
down the tree to the
corresponding album member's
object and see if the sign in
user is listed as the owner.
Then congratulations you can
read and write to this album
joiner's object.  And then we
also want to say album owners
can alter anything in theironal
bum object which say simpler
rule.  We say if you're listed,
then write in here.  And then
for brand new albums, we'll say
that any owner can create
anybody a brand new album as
long as they list themselves as
the owner.  That's what you do
here.  We say you can create a
new album object as long as it
doesn't already exist and you
are the the owner.  So maybe
your first reaction upon seeing
all of this is, I'm going to
give up and make my database all
readable and writable because
this seems strange and wierd.
And it is.  It is kind of
strange and wierd at first.  I
certainly wasn't able to figure
this out without having a
Firebase engineer next to me and
I know all of you don't have
the value of having a engineer
sitting next to you.  About you
I can give you the next best
thing, his phone number.  Frank.
He is willing to help out and
answer questions.  I'm sorry?
Apparently that was not a
sincere - I'm just going to move
on.  Instead I'm going to say
get the next next best thing
which is this cool tool that
Firebase has where you can
pretend to signed sign in as any
user and simulate any kind of
read or write call and what will
happen is Firebase will go
through all of the rules in the
database and let you know which
ones it is applying, whether it
evaluates to true or false and
then tell you whether this
operation would have succeeded
or not.  So it is kind of cool.
Like that is how I was able to
verify that all of these rules
on my Slides were legit was by
sort of going through all the
simulated reads and writes and
making sure that yes, someone
can, an owner is allowed to
remove somebody from the
joiner's list and so on.  I
encourage to you give this a
try.  It's available the UI
improved a little bit as well.
It's available in the database
in this button on the right that
says -- I forget what it says
now.  Like experiments or
something like that.
So because these rules they are
wierd at first but they are also
incredibly powerful.  Once you
starred playing with them, they
can be kind of fun and I know
security isn't supposed to be
fun.  It's supposed to be very
serious and all that but it's
fun to play around with.
So let's move on to trick Number
3.  We test in production or
using road config plus Crash
Reporting plus Analytics plus
notifications to turn disasters
around.  So, let's revisit
ticket picker.  And one day
their CEO says I have this great
idea for a new ticket auction
feature.  Instead of just
selling and buying tickets,
we'll let people put their
tickets up for auction and
everybody can bid and like
whoever the highest bidder is
gets the ticket.  Does not this
sound fantastic?  It does.  I'm
glad you agree because I told
our investors we would have it
ready by income week.  Don't
worry, I have a plan.  I have
been analyzing all the work we
do.  Turns out it breaks down
into four things here.  We
develop features, cool features
and write the unit test and add
in sweet an maitions and compose
funny release notes.  We are
doing a whole Calvin and Hobbs
fiction thing that is very
popular.  We analyze this stuff
and found out that people love
the features and the animations
and release notes.  Totally fun
and interesting.  But writing
unit test are so boring.  I
looked at all the time engineers
spend writing these and not one
good feature has come out.
Just skip it.  Tara from
engineering was not super
impressed when while the CEO
decided to push forward with the
whole test plan, he made one
valuable concession, all right
let's role it out gradually.  So
the first day we'll role it out
to like a very small percentage
of the population and then
we'll expand it.  And maybe in a
couple of days we'll go to 15%
and so on until the entire world
is full of our red auction
goodness.  So here is how they
did it.  Here is how you do a
gradual roll out using Firebase.
First off, they added a ticket
auction enabled value in
Firebase Remote Config so this
is basically a value that you
can read in from a real config
that says, should I enable this
option?  What can you do in real
config is create conditions.
Certain Groups of users for whom
certain values apply.  And one
thing you can do with conditions
is create random Groups of
users.  They said we are going
to create a ticket auction
experiment condition which will
apply to 10% of the population.
Or this can be whatever we
want.  We'll start with 10.  So
we'll flag this value or set
this value to true if they are
in the ticket auction experiment
and otherwise we will set it to
false.  And because Karen is
super paranoid, she said let's
also suppress that review
dialogue for anybody that is in
that experiment because I'm not
entirely sure we want to
encourage reviews from people in
this thing yet.  I'm not super
confident yet in our auction
feature.  So that is something
you can also do pretty easily
using Remote Config is change
when you want to show that.
Please review our dialogue to
users.
So then in their code it's
simple to usury moat config to
whether or not to enable this
feature.  And then basically
also report back through
Firebase Analytics the
experiment type that the user is
in by setting auer property.
So we'll create a user property
called, is this user in the
auction experiment and set it to
1 or 0 if they are in the
auction.  And then Firebase
Analytics, let's create an
audience based on people for
whom this experiment type is
equal to true.  So for anybody
who has user property of I am in
this experiment, we will add
them to a Firebase audience and
the wear Firebase audiences is
work is they buildup over time.
It's distributed to the client.
So as people start using the
app and the client realizes they
are in this auction experiment,
they will get added to this
audience.  So, our app is
updated and released to the
world and we decide to gradually
turn on this feature by
changing the percent in the
experiment T will go from 2% to
like 10% and then 20% and so on.
And we change these random
values, it is that same random
group of 10% plus the next
random group of 10T doesn't pick
an entirely different 20% of
the population.  So we gradually
role it out to our users and
then we decide to see how things
are going.  So we go over and
look on Firebase Crash Reporting
and this is terrible.  And if
we look below, the biggest
culprit seems to be a method,
start new auction.  So,
apparently that might be the
culprit and even worse, we can
go and break out our spending
reports by this user property
and see that people who are now
in the auction experiment aren't
spending everything and this is
terrible and our CEO goes to
engineering and says how could
have let this happen?  And Karen
sighs and says don't worry, we
have a plan.  So first of all,
we can usury moat config to shut
down the experiment.  We change
this condition back to zero and
the auction disappears from
everybody's app.  We have an
audience full of everybody who
is in this experiment and we can
apologize to them and it is
amazing how much goodwill you
can gain when you apologize when
you mess things up.
Sorry about the lineos
Wednesday.  Anyway, we can use
Firebase Notifications to send
an apology to everybody in that
audience saying hey, sorry we
had some issues with our
auctions.  We turned off this
feature and maybe as an added
bonus, here is a little coupon
code or something in the
notification.  And because it is
being targeted to just this
audience, the other 80% of the
population using the app isn't
like, what are they talking
about?  I never seen this.  So
this sort of thing can be
useful.  It's a good way of
turning a negative experience
into a positive one and show how
you care.  Karen saves the
company and everything is good
with the world.  Stop coming up
with ideas.  They are all
terrible.
Let's move on to trick Number 4.
The dreaming boy store front
Analytics plus AdWords plus
Remote Config plus Firebase
Hosting equal promotions to
swoon over.  Chat em up is a new
chat app that makes most money
selling stickners their in-App
Store.  It happens that the lead
person at which the em up is
really good friends with the
Manager of The hot new boy band
coming out of the U.K., the
dream boys.  So, the hot new
band with the hit new song, you
can't debug my love.  Freaky
looking boy band.  And so
anyway, they say you know what
would be great?  What if we had
a dreamy boys branded seconds of
our sticker shop.  That would
be fantastic.  They start
negotiating deals and royalties
and all that.  We decided we
wanted to make this thing a
success as soon as it launches.
So as early as we can, we will
start creating a few audiences
and in Firebase Analytics and
target their initial
demographic, females in the
U.K., second demographic is
males in Switzerland over 55.
I'll be hon theft took marketing
by surprise but there you go.
And then target our heavy
sticker users.  These are people
who purchased a sticker from
our in-app sticker store.  That
is probably an audience we
created already because we care
about them.  Very clearly the
people that are going to most
likely to purchase stickers in
the future are people probably
purchased stickers in the past.
This is definitely ef a group
we want to capture in a Firebase
Analytics audience.  Let's fast
forward to a few months later.
The deal is signed.  We have a
new store front and stay that is
fantastic.  We have should to
get the word out.  So because we
connected Firebase in AdWords,
we can use these
audiences directly in our
remarketing campaign.  If you
have done a remarketing campaign
in AdWords, you might know that
you're allowed to basically
target specific remarketing
lists and these can be everybody
who has ever used your app ever
but now that you can connect
Firebase and AdWords, you can
target audiences you built-up
right within Analytics and that
turns out to be really useful.
Like we can actually target just
the people that purchased
stickers in our app before with
remarketing campaigns.  Sore we
can also target our women in the
U.K. and older Swiss men.
And so those people will start
to see remarketing adds designed
to get them into their app and
hopefully making more purchases.
It turns out we could use
Remote Config to display a
message to our sticker audience
create conditions based on
random Groups of users or your
device type or your country.
But we can also tar get certain
Firebase audiences.  So we
coulda add a welcome message to
let them know about recent new
addition to our app.  And
honestly, this is a good
application for Remote Config is
any kind of message of the day
feature.  You can immediately
push out any new message you
want to send to your users using
Remote Config.  And with
conditions, you can target just
specific Groups of users who
might be interested.  So not
everybody is getting all these
message of the days all the time
if they don't want them.  And
we can also do things as long as
we are using Remote Config,
change the banner image for our
sticker store so it can be
something special for that group
of users who purchased stickers
from us in the past.  Maybe we
say instead of using whatever
local image we would normally
use on the device, let's grab
something remotely.  And so we
can go from our boring old
sticker shop banner to whatever
you call this.  That's Evan.
The rebel of the group.  I hear
he might be a vampire as well.
We are going for smoldering but
I think we just ended up with
tired bauds that is whatness
when you take pictures the week
before I/O.  Everyone looks
tired!
But that is the kind of thing to
do with Remote Config.  And by
the way, I don't know if you
noticed, the URL for that banner
image is being provided by
Firebase Hosting and that is the
best place for need to put
static images you want to
retrieve by using HTP calls and
that's a good question.  So yes,
you may have noticed two ways
to retrieve images.  Have you
Firebase Storage and Firebase
Hosting.  Both are good.
Generally speaking, you want to
use Firebase Storage for user
generated content.  Images that
users have up loaded,
recordings, that sort of thing.
Federal what I call read only
assets, like your ebb site and
images and data you want your
app to download later, Hosting
is appropriate.  It gets it out
to the world everywhere and
makes it super fast and easier
for you to download also free I
believe, which is nice.
So let's move on to trick Number
5.  Are you ready for this
jelly?  Or basically Remote
Config plus Dynamic Links plus
Firebase database and Firebase
Analytics for replays that
matter.  Let's talk about the
latest match puzzle game.  The
developers wanted to add a share
my level feature so if you had
a great replay, you can send it
to your friends.  They can try
the exact same level and see if
they can beat your score and
watch your replay later.  It
sound like a cool way of doing
it.  So again, this seems like a
uses case for Dynamic Links.
Whatever e-mail this app
generates for whatever post or
how we want to share this
replay, we probably want that
link to get into our app to be
Dynamic Link so click on that
link and take them into the app
and load up the level by
analyzing that link parameter
and they don't have the app
installed so we can take them to
the play store or App Store.
And we totally store all that
replay information in the
Firebase database.
But there is one big question.
So typically, if user doesn't
have the app installed, the
default Dynamic Link process is
to take users to the App Store
or play store and wait for them
to install the app.  You values
another option when dealing with
Firebase Dynamic Links.  We can
send people to a fall-back page
instead, like a marketing page
where we tell them more about
the app and how fantastic it is
and get them excited about it
before we send them to the App
Store where they are given the
option of whether to install it
or not.  And there is advantages
and disvalues to both.  The
first way is one fewer click.
You can get into the app or play
store immediately but the other
way, maybe gives the user more
context before we ask them to
install something H is better?
It seems like a good opportunity
for a AB test.
That is something we can do with
Remote Config.  Cest up a test
condition delivering to a random
group of users and we'll look
at 50% of our users instead
doing a gradual roll out so do a
true AB test.
And then we can set our value of
replay uses marketing page to
be true or false depending on
the useners this experiment and
then basically within whatever
code we are going to be using to
build out this Dynamic Link
from the app, we can look and
see, is this value true?  If so,
then let's add on these two
extra parameters, the A if.  L
and IFL parameter to our Dynamic
Link which tells Firebase
Dynamic Links what Web page to
send the user to instead.  So
half of our users the link they
will share with friends looks
like this.  And the other half
will have a link that looks like
this, basically the same link
as before but now we have these
fall back page URLs specified.
And again with the tiny bit of
JavaScript, that marketing page
that we then have that tells the
user how fantastic this app is
and now don't you really want to
go and install it?  When they
click on the link to install, we
can still kind of generate our
own Dynamic Link so that when
the user does open up that app,
we remembered through the entire
process what that replay was
and take our user right into
that replay as soon as they
start up the app.  And how do we
track this?  How do we see
which is successful?  The
easiest way is to adjust the
parameters that we talked about
earlier.  We can create that for
each link.  And then start
tracking conversion metrics.
Like who made the in app
purchase based on did you visit
the fall back page first or
taken there directly from the
e-mail?  And so not only can we
see which users clicked on which
links the most but also see
which users then stuck around
and made a purchase and got into
it.  Maybe the marketing page
got you more psyched to try the
app and stick with it because
chances are, you're not going to
win that replay if this is the
first time you ever tried the
game.  So that is valuable.
And by the way, you don't need
to stop with testing a single
page or not.  It's very easy to
ABC test different pages.
Create conditions for 33% of
over use and 66% and then set
different options of which
marketing page do we send people
to or maybe we don't send them
to one at all.  Based on these
conditions.  And we think about
it, if this e-mail content is
being generated, it has tho come
from somewhere too.  Why not
use Remote Config to test what
e-mails we are going to send and
test what screenshot the app is
going to put in there.  What
the button will say.  All that
stuff fairly easy to set up and
AB test using Remote Config.  So
there you go.  5 ways to use
elements like Storage and
Analytics and notifications and
Remote Config and all together
to make a more compelling app.
This might shock some of you but
these were contrived examples
with fake companies.  I know.
Right.  Surprising.
But probably some of this does
apply to your situation.  Maybe
you have a companion site where
you're trying to bring users
into your app and you want to
make that more powerful.  Or
maybe an added feature you're
not confident in and maybe you
want to try a gradual roll out
first.  Maybe you have your own
set of deep links or sharing
e-mails and you want to AB test
that stuff.  So think about it.
Maybe a couple of these
examples might not be exactly
pertinent to your situation but
maybe they will inspire to you
think of something similar that
would be cool.  So I know at
this point I'm like the teacher
on the last day of class and
everybody is waiting for the
bell to ring.  Maybe some of you
have planes to catch.  I just
want to say thank you very much
for coming to I/O.  Every year
like the week before I'm always
up super late and not sleeping
and trying to get this stuff
done and is this worth it?  And
then I come to these events and
talk to people who are like
super excited and positive and a
little bit nerdy like me, and
it's just really nice.  Like
it's just really nice to be able
to sort of chat with all of you
and sort of meet other people
and please just continue to be
positive and a little bit nerdy
because I think that is great.
So anyway, sorry.  If you want
more information about Firebase,
here is the website.  We have a
support page and a YouTube and
Twitter feed and with that, I'm